From the library of
congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Jennifer Manning: Good
morning, can everyone hear me?
Good. I'm Jennifer Manning.
I'm a librarian with the
Congressional Research Service here
at the library.
On behalf of Native American
employees and friends at the library
of congress, I'd like to welcome you
to this Native American
heritage month event.
Thank you for coming and celebrating
with us on this rather gloomy day.
We have a full day ahead of
us, so without further ado,
it's my pleasure to
introduce the library's Chief
of Staff, Mr. Robert Newlen.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Robert Newlen: Well
thank you and good morning.
I have been Chief of Staff here at
the library for just about one year.
In fact, I've been celebrating
several anniversaries
in the past week.
I have been Chief of
Staff for a year
and I celebrated my 40th
Anniversary of employment
with the Library of Congress.
And I could-- [applause]--
thank you.
Yes, I know it's amazing
that I'm still standing.
But it's a wonderful institution and
a wonderful place to have a career
and I'm really looking
forward to you learning more
about our many resources today.
One thing I should note too is, this
is my maiden voyage using an iPad
for my remarks but, the acting
Librarian of Congress, David Mao,
uses one all the time and
he's very facile with it.
So I've seen him speak enough and I
kind of got jealous and I thought,
well he's making me look like a
troglodyte so I'm going to do it.
But I just want you to know that
I'm also carrying the paper copy
in my back pocket because
you never know.
But it is my pleasure to welcome
you to the Library of Congress
and today's program showcasing three
LC programs and your opportunity
to connect with our collections
that showcase the great heritage
of American Indians who
have lived on this land
for thousands and thousands
of years.
The library as you probably know
has over-- there I just did it--
has over fifteen million
items in all formats.
We acquire them, we prepare them, we
organize them, and we preserve them.
Today's theme is Connecting American
Indian and Federal Libraries
and our goal for you
in the audience,
whether you are listening online
or viewing this through a webcast,
is to learn about Native
American Research and Resources
at the Library of Congress.
But I hope you will also get to know
one of our greatest treasures here
at the library, and that is
the Library of Congress staff.
They have incredible knowledge
of our collections and are here
to help you navigate this
marvelous institution.
You will find lots of people like me
that have been here 35, 40, 45 years
and sometimes at this stage I think
it takes that long to really get
to know the Library of Congress
collections and when I look
around this room I see
so many talented people.
Beacher [assumed spelling],
Yolanda, Blaine, Jennifer, Eric.
All people who have incredible
knowledge of this great institution,
so today please take
advantage of them,
and I know they will all
share their e-mails with you.
Today we are going to have
presentations from 3 major programs
that further our work
with American Indians.
In just a few moments
we'll learn about the work
of the FEDLINK American
Library Initiative.
At noon, a former Kluge
scholar and a panel
of cultural experts will talk about
federal and regional Native history.
And at 2 p.m. the Law Library will
present the indigenous tribal law
portal which is available online.
And in between, you'll be seeing
presentations from our curators,
from the geography and map division,
from prints and photographs,
from manuscripts, and
from rare books.
What we're hoping is, is that what
you find here today will wet your
appetite to keep coming
back again and again.
We also hope that it will help
you find a place to expand
and deepen your understanding of
Native American, American Indian
and indigenous peoples
of the world who link us
to a great past and
to a great future.
We invite you to continue learning
about our cooperative web portal
nativeamericanhertiagemonth.com I
think I got that right.
So with that said, it is my
pleasure to welcome you here
and anything we can do to make
your visit more enjoyable,
please let us know.
I'm hoping to come in and
out of the program today.
I feel like I'm on
the lecture circuit.
I'm going directly from here
to talk to a management group
about our strategic plan.
Trust me, I'd rather be here.
So with that, thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> George Franchois:
Okay, let's see here.
All right.
Unfortunately, I don't
have an iPad yet.
I am keeping my fingers
crossed for Christmas,
but we shall see what happens.
So I'm doing this the
old fashion way.
My name is George Franchois.
I'm the Director of the Department
of the Interior Library here
in Washington DC and I'm going
to talk to you a little bit
about the Department of the Interior
Library and the Tribal College
and University Library Initiative
that we are very much involved with.
So first I want to
tell you a little bit
about the Department of
the Interior Library.
We are located again
here in Washington DC
in the Stewart Lee Udall
Department of the Interior Building,
1849 C Street Northwest, Room 2262.
We are open to the public.
We're open from 7:45
a.m. to 5 p.m. Monday
through Friday except
for federal holidays.
We will be closed tomorrow
for Veteran's Day.
We do provide inner
library loan services.
We both lend things out to other
libraries around the country,
and it doesn't matter,
public libraries,
university libraries,
corporate libraries.
We will loan things out to you
that are circulating materials,
and we of course process
in our library loan request
for our own staff as well.
Our website is www.doi.gov/library.
We've got a lot of great resources
on our website including a lot
of great Native American resources
on our website, so we invite you
to take a look at that site for
information about the Department
of the Interior, our library,
and Native American Resources.
Now currently our library
is in the midst
of a 2-year modernization/renovation
project.
So we are actually operating
out of a much smaller
temporary library right now.
Most of our popular
legal legislative
and reference materials are
located in our temporary library,
but about 90 to 95 percent of
our material right now is located
in an offsite warehouse
in Sterling, Virginia.
We do have a courier service that
goes back and forth twice a week
so if that we need materials
from the warehouse we
can get them pulled.
And we are like I said scheduled
to reopen probably
late 2016, early 2017.
Some of our facilities people are
telling me, it could be as early
as next October, but I'm
not holding my breath
on that one knowing our
facilities people at DOI.
So we shall see what
happens there as well.
We've got about a one million
volume collection all together.
Things that we collect
include materials published
by all the DOI bureaus,
offices, and agencies as well
as commercial publications that
have subject areas that deal
with Department of
the Interior issues.
So we collect things
from all of our bureaus.
Like I said, the Bureau of
Indian Affairs we collect a lot
of materials from, National Park
Service, Bureau of Land Management,
Bureau of Reclamation, Fish
and Wildlife Service, USGS,
several others as well and it's not
just BIA that produces materials
that deal with Native
American issues.
All of the agencies within
the Department of the Interior
to one extent to another have
materials that they published
that deal with Native American
heritage, history, current events
that Native Americans were involved
with, etc. So almost everything
in our collection in one way
or another touches the
Native American community.
We also have a legal and
administrative collection
that includes bureau and
agency directives and orders,
secretarial orders, and executive
orders and proclamations.
And again many of these items
also contain materials related
to Native American affairs.
So how did this whole
movement to try
to help Native American libraries,
and specifically Tribal College
and university libraries
get started?
It basically had its
genesis back in 2002,
with Executive Order
number 13270, July 3rd 2002,
entitled Tribal College
and Universities
and this said each participating
executive department and agency is
to develop plans that would
address how the agency intends
to increase the capacity of tribal
colleges to compete effectively
for any available grants,
contracts, cooperative agreements,
and any other federal resources,
and to encourage tribal colleges
to participate in federal programs.
The plans also may emphasize access
to high quality educational
opportunities
for economically disadvantaged
Indian students,
consistent with requirements of
No child Left Behind Act of 2001.
So at this point what happened was
organizations such as the Institute
for Museum and Library Services
placed an increased emphasis
on providing grants and other
opportunities for tribal colleges
and university libraries.
The Bureau of Indian
Education within the Department
of the Interior began to
work a little more closely
with tribal college and
university libraries,
and the American Indian Higher
Education Contortion also started
to work a little more closely with
tribal colleges and universities
on mutually beneficial projects.
The one thing though
that was going on at
that time was a case called the
Cobell case, and I think many
of you might be familiar
with that case
where Native American tribes were
suing the Department of the Interior
for mishandling Indian trust funds.
So there was a high degree
at that point of mistrust
between Native American tribes
and the Department of the Interior
and not as much really got done
on this front as we would've hoped
to have gotten done at that point.
So because of the suspicions that
existed between the Department
of the Interior and a lot
of Native American tribes,
a lot of these initiatives
unfortunately were put off a little
bit at that time.
So we fast forward to February
14th, 2011, Valentine's Day
which is a great day
for a [inaudible]
of understanding, of course.
So MOU was signed between the
Bureau of Indian Education
and the American Indian
Higher Education Consortium.
By February 14th, 2011 the
Cobell case had been settled,
and the suspicions were
still there a little bit,
a lot of those suspicions and a
lot of those mistrusts had kind
of evaporated as a result of
the settlement being reached.
So the memorandum of understanding
stated that DOI and AIHEC will focus
on strengthening the
capacities of TCU's
and supporting their
full integration
into DOI's programs and services.
This MOU will also promote
enriching outdoor experiences
and law enforcement and natural
resources and other science
and technology career pathways.
Amongst students attending TCU's
and their feeder K-12 schools.
Part of the initiative, part of this
memorandum of understanding also was
to fully integrate TCU's into DOI
mission areas and bureau programs,
services and resource
opportunities and provide linkage
and develop partnerships
between TCU's
and DOI and bureaus and offices.
Part of what happened as a
result-- let me go back here--
as a result of this as well,
it is that the Department
of the Interior Library was
brought into the process
and asked how can the Department
of the Interior Library participate
and contribute to this initiative,
to this MOU that was signed in 2011?
And this is when we first
heard about getting started
with this particular initiative.
Soon thereafter, December 2nd,
2011 an executive order was
signed improving American Indian
and Alaskan Native
educational opportunities
and strengthening tribal
colleges and universities.
And what this did was established
a formal White House Initiative
on American Indian and
Alaska Native Education.
The Secretary of Education
and the Secretary
of the Interior are
co-chairs of the initiative.
Missions of the initiative,
service liaison
with other executive branch
agencies on American Indian
and Alaskan Native issues
and advise those agencies
on how they might help
promote American Indian
and Alaskan Native
educational opportunities.
Further tribal sovereignty
by supporting efforts,
consistent with applicable
law, to build the capacity
of tribal educational
agencies and TCU's
to provide high quality education
services to American Indian
and Alaska Native children
and increase college access
and completion for American
Indian and Alaska Native students
through strategies to
strengthen the capacity of TCU's.
So in early 2002, the Bureau of
Indian Education with NDOI met
with representatives of other
DOI bureaus and agencies
to discuss how we can
best go about doing this.
The office of the secretary
again asked DOI's library
to help participate in this and
asked if we can expand our services
and outreach to TCU's
through their libraries.
Now of course, our
budget is not as such
that we could expand our budget too
dramatically to help with this sort
of effort, so it had be
something that we could do
that wouldn't necessarily cost
a lot of money to the library
or to the Department of the Interior
a lot of ideas were presented
to TCU presidents and
there was a lot of interest
within the TCU community and
the library services assistance
to their own libraries and
their own library communities.
So at that point we
got together with AIHEC
and discussed what the best way
to start this project would be.
So we received a list of
libraries and library leaders
at 37 AIHEC member libraries
and sent out a survey to all
of them asking them a number
of different questions.
They included questions about
high-speed internet access
in their library and on
campus, electronic databases
and e-book subscriptions in
their library, and whether
or not they had inner
library loan services, whether
or not they received
government documents
through the GPO's Federal
Depository Library Program.
And we asked them about other
items, services and resources
that they felt they needed
to provide quality services
to their students and staff.
We received responses from
19 AIHEC member libraries
as a result of that survey.
And some of the things
that they told us were
that they needed additional
staffing,
they needed additional funding
to purchase to more resources,
they need additional funding
to offset the increasing prices
of databases and print materials.
They would like consortium pricing
for databases integrated
library systems.
They were interested in inner
library loan reciprocal lending
agreements and a possible TCU
inner library loan consortium.
They wanted more computers
in their libraries.
They wanted the means to be able
to remote library services
and resources.
They needed better
transportation to TCU libraries
that weren't centrally
located within the communities.
They needed additional training
for library staff and students
and online databases, and
many of them need additional
or even adequate space for their
libraries with new furniture.
Some of the things
that the Department
of the Interior Library
took out of that as far
as things we would be able
to provide the TCU libraries
as a result of their
survey included:
Reciprocal Interlibrary
Loan Services
where we'd encourage TCU libraries
to borrow circulating materials
from our collection;
reference services
where we would encourage
TCU students and faculty
to contact our library for any
reference assistance and instances
where they couldn't
necessarily have the resources
to answer those questions
themselves;
government document assistance
encouraging TCU libraries
to contact the DOI library
for assistance in locating
and obtaining federal government
documents, especially documents
that were originated from the
Department of the Interior;
and remote online access
to library classes.
The DOI library promotes and
hosts a lot of training classes
and other types of programs and we
wanted to encourage them to be able
to attend our classes via webinar
or some other remote means.
So what we did was
presented all of these ideas
at a FEDLINK meeting soon
thereafter and we found
that FEDLINK was also very
much interested in helping
with this project and
promoting this project
to other FEDLINK member libraries.
We were very pleased to hear that
and very pleased at the response
from many FEDLINK libraries as
they also expressed their interest
in joining with us on this project
and soon thereafter the American
Indian library Initiative working
group here at Fed link was indeed
formed and continues to this day.
So with that, I will turn
things over to Gary McCone ,
Gary is with the American Indian
Higher Education Consortium
and he will tell you
a little bit more
about AIHECs involvement
in this project.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Gary McCone: Well this
is going to be really short
because George just gave my speech
and so it's more dramatic
with paper.
I don't know where Robert is but
if try doing this with an iPad,
it cost you a lot of
money so don't do that.
I am Gary McCone.
I'm with AIHEC.
Maybe I should mention,
I'm a volunteer.
They don't pay me, but it's
so much fun so I do it anyway.
American Indian-- I don't have
to explain what AIHEC is, no,
because you already know this.
Thank you, George.
All this detail, I can
skip about 20 slides now,
and go right into in case you
don't know, I think George said
with there were 37 at the time.
I think there's 38 now.
The Pawnee Nation College
has just come on board.
Basically they're out in the West
as you might know, maybe suspect
or maybe not suspect,
but they are scattered
around essentially the mountain
states, a couple in the Southwest.
The oldest one is Denay College
down in Arizona was formed in 1968.
The newest one I think was last
week, Pawnee Nation College
and there's a couple of others
out there that are in the process
of getting together, getting
facilities, getting accreditation
and then once they get
accreditation, then they can apply
and be part of AIHEC
if they want to.
And most of them want to.
There seems to be a genuine benefit
to them for being in AIHEC so,
I think, okay I like this.
It depends on what version
of PowerPoint you use
whether your pictures are
in the right places or not.
So we do have curriculum suppor
[phonetic] which is a good thing.
And Native studies call so those
are two really important issues.
Underfunded.
I just put that in because
everybody's underfunded.
Travel colleges and universities
are really underfunded.
The size of the collection,
I mean I've heard from people
who are just starting out who
have, well we have a bookcase
but we don't have any books on it.
So that's one level and
you have other one's
that have maybe 50,000 item
collection, something like that,
so I'm not counting microphage and
all these things that librarians
like to count to get their
statistics up but real books.
They do get funding, the
colleges I should say,
get funding from the
federal government based
on enrollment, FDE enrollment.
And so there's some fudging
of statistics I think
on everybody's side, when
they start counting this.
If they have to pay for something,
then they want their enrollment low.
Like if you have 2,000 users on a
database, that gets you once price.
If you have 5,000,
that's a different price.
But it also effects the
amount of money you receive
from the federal government.
A lot of people think that the
tribal colleges because all
but 3 of them are on
reservation land,
and everyone knows reservations all
have casino's and so there's lots
of money, and there's
probably a lot of money
but you'd be surprised
how little of it,
goes to the education
system on the reservations.
Curriculum suppor [phonetic].
I think there's a T
hiding back there.
Many of the libraries don't have a
materials budget that allows them
to buy them anything other than
strict curriculum-related materials.
They can't branch out
and buy other things.
They can't get supportive
materials, they can't,
they just can't do much other
than this very specifically
support the curriculum
which really limits the size of
the collection and the use of it.
Almost all of them
claim to have or try
to have a Native Studies Collection.
Some of them have, I think, really
good Native Studies Collections.
Denay has a really good one.
I think, Little Big Horn has
a really good Native Studies
Collection, but for
the most part they try.
Most of them also serve
as a public library,
so when you can't buy books
except for curriculum,
that really limits the
public library aspect of it.
They serve preschool to elders,
not just people who are enrolled
in the college so that's an issue.
Digital resources, I think George
mentioned the number of different,
I guess on the survey that
they, well he didn't specifics
on who had what but a lot of
them do have digital resources.
And it's sort of interesting
because I've tried
to get different consortium
pricing on different collections
of electronic journals or databases,
and it's interesting because,
of course all of the vendors
are willing to give me a price,
but the problem is a
lot of these colleges,
depending on what state there in,
they already get a good
deal within the state.
Minnesota or Wyoming or somebody
like that, the state pays for it.
They don't have to pay anything
to get into this consortium.
Other one's provide an entryway
into the consortium but they have
to pay a really reduced rate, and so
that's great for the ones that have
that kind of an arrangement,
but it seems that most
states don't do that.
You're on your own.
You are in, either is in the
state consortium or there is one
but you can't get in unless
you pay a full percentage
or a full ticket, so
that's an issue.
And when I get a consortial price
for all 37 or 38, often the ones
that are getting really good deal,
so it makes no sense for us to get
into this because we are
already getting it more cheaply
and so almost every one of those has
fallen through just because of that.
When I go back to ProQuest
or whoever and say well,
okay, how about for this many?
So well then the price
per institution goes
up as you would expect.
I mean, they're in it to make money.
Okay, the great book giveaway.
This is something that's been
going on for a long time now
and here's pictures from-- this
is something that in conjunction
with surplus books programs
here at the Library of Congress,
National Museum of American
Indian, and we've gotten books
from DC chapter of the
Special Libraries Association,
from Fannie Mae, from the Department
of Education, and individuals,
Maryland Chapter of Mensa.
They've all chipped in books
to go out to these colleges.
So every year we send out
about-National Agricultural Library,
I should mention since they pay the
shipping bill for all the books.
I send out a list 4
times a year maybe
and let them pick the
titles they want.
So they don't get one's-it's not
just, here's a bunch of books
because that doesn't work.
They pick the titles, I send them
out, and they get what they want.
And so that's sort of a fun
thing that they like to do.
I think maybe, well you
can see from the pictures,
there's really a wide range, I think
of-I guess what I would say is,
look at the pictures, they
just look like libraries.
There not any different from
any other public library mainly.
There are certainly some things
that cater to a pre-k crowd
that you can see, but
they're basically just
like any other library
that you think about except
for the staffing can run
from one part-time person,
and that's a number of them,
or they can get a student
help maybe sometimes.
I don't know what the-- I'm going
to say that the, if you look at,
some of them have multiple branches
so if you exclude the
multiple branch libraries,
I say the most staff that any
of them have is probably six.
And I may be way off but I
can't be off by more than six.
So that's basically it, and
I thank George for giving
such a great background
on AIHEC's involvement
in all these things because, frankly
I didn't know any of this stuff.
And so now we'll be able
to look at his slides
and be able to learn it all.
Okay, and now I would like to
introduce my twin for the day,
Blane Dessey, acting
Executive Director of FEDLINK
who I have known for
several years now.
[ Applause ]
>> Blane Dessey: Thank you.
>> Gary McCone: You notice,
we both got the memo?
>> Blane Dessey: Exactly, exactly.
Twins separated at birth.
>> Gary McCone: Exactly.
There you go.
>>Blane Dessey: Thank you.
Let me just-- okay.
I think I can do this.
Good morning everyone and
welcome to the Library of Congress
and welcome to this program.
I am Blane Dessey.
I'm the acting Executive Director
of FEDLINK for another few days
when we will be welcoming
a new director to FEDLINK
and I will ensure that one of her
priorities is to continue work
on this project, but
let me try and put some
of these puzzle pieces together,
especially for those of you
who are not familiar with
the government as such.
So earlier we heard George
talk about the efforts
of the Department of the Interior.
Great effort.
And we've just heard Gary talk
about the efforts of AIHEC,
did I pronounce that correctly?
>> AIHEC.
>> Blane Dessey: AIHEC, I'm sorry.
And I'm here to talk a little bit
about FEDLINK and so
what is FEDLINK?
FEDLINK is the Federal Library
and Information Network.
It's an organization of federal
agencies working together
to achieve optimum use of
the resources and facilities
of federal libraries
and information centers.
I'm not going to read this
slide for you word for word.
But here's what I want to
bring to your attention.
I don't think many people
realize the power and the impact
that federal libraries could
have on this particular issue.
When we had tried to do a survey
of all the federal libraries,
we've determined that
there are probably
at least 1,500 federal
libraries around the world,
if not close to closer to 2,000.
All right.
So if you look at this as some
sort of a government enterprise,
this is the largest library
structure in the world,
in the history of man
for that matter.
I mean that's quite impressive
when you began to think of power
of that many libraries
focusing on a particular issue.
It really sort of staggers
the imagination.
And so what I keep wanting to
impress upon people is that,
taken collectively, federal
libraries can make a huge impact
in terms of services,
in terms of resources,
and in terms of education
to the American people.
You know, Gary just said that many
of the libraries that he works with
or like public libraries and
many of the libraries that are
in the federal government
are like public libraries.
George works in what is
in fact a public library.
The Library of Congress, I
mention this and people always kind
of shudder when I say this,
the Library of Congress
is a public library just
like the National Library
of Medicine,
just like National
Agricultural Library
and if we could really harness
all this library energy,
or all this intellectual energy,
to work with tribal colleges
and universities or tribal nations,
I think there could be huge impacts.
So I guess what I'm really saying
is I'm committed to working
with federal libraries
through FEDLINK,
and if you're in this room I'm
hoping that you would also sort
of commit to this cause with
us, that the power of all of us
to work together can be
really quite significant.
So that's my soapbox and now
I'll move on to other things.
So how did FEDLINK, which
is this organization,
really put tribal colleges and
universities on its radar screen?
Well it really began back in
2012 when George Franchois,
and let me say George is too modest
to say this but he has been one
of the driving forces
behind this entire effort.
So George will never tell you that,
but much of this would
not have happened
without George's direct
involvement, so kudos to George.
The Department of the Interior
approached the FEDLINK advisory
board to talk about
what could be done.
George shared with us
the results of the survey
and he was particularly
interested in FEDLINK'S ability
to negotiate consortium
pricing for services,
and we have some legal issues with
that, that we're trying to resolve
because tribal nations
are not considered part
of the federal government even
though they receive federal funding,
but anyway, but there are other
things that we can be thinking
about too as in education and
collaboration and resource sharing.
And when George brought this
notion to my advisory board,
which is comprised of other
federal agencies, everyone was very,
very supportive of the idea.
And they felt that, yes, we as a
federal library community do want
to have a responsibility in
improving the lives of students
and faculty at those
tribal institutions,
that we can really make
a contribution especially
since so many of us have
public mission to begin with,
that we have no reason not to make
an effort to extend our services
and resources to those
tribal members.
And so that began in 2012 and then
we also began to work with one
of our favorite external
organizations,
the Institute for Museum
and Library Services.
Now, which is known
as IMLS, IMLS is,
and Mary Alice might tell you
this, is a federal organization
which awards grants to public
schools and other types of libraries
around the United States,
not federal libraries.
We have a very clear
delineation between the two.
But my contention is that because
so many federal libraries
have a public library
or a school library purpose,
there areas of common interest
between what we're attempting
to do in the federal government
and what IMLS is trying to
do for the United States.
And so we decided to put
together a program in 2014,
American Indian Libraries Making
Connections to highlight the stories
of five recent IMLS
library grant recipients.
This program was a huge success
by all accounts and it was really
because of the efforts Terry
Devoe who is sitting here
and also her colleague, Mary Alice
Ball, who's sitting next to her.
But this was really our first
foray into a kind of programing
that shows we can work across
boundaries to illustrate the issue
and to talk about solutions
to those issues,
so we were very proud of that.
And when we saw the kind of response
that we got, this just fueled us
to continue to discuss what we might
do in the federal library community.
So at this point we decided,
well we've done enough talking,
we've done enough thinking, we've
experimented with some programs,
let's do something
a little more formal
as a federal library community.
And think of this as a community,
not just the Library of Congress.
This is a community.
We decided to create what we
normally do, a working group,
which is how we work within
our community, called AILI,
which is the American
Indian Library Initiative,
as a way to focus our efforts to
really work with tribal colleges
and universities and tribal
nations because we also realized
that there is information needs
outside of colleges and universities
but to really work with a
group of federal libraries
to bring improvements-- I hope
that doesn't sound too judgmental--
to sort of work with
Native communities
to improve their library
resources and initiatives.
So we have created this standing
working group that meets regularly
and several people here
are involved in that.
And the goals were really quite
straight forward but ambitious
and that is to build an
information culture from local
to local and local to national.
I think part of our job in FEDLINK
is to always be raising awareness
and to be advocating for issues.
We need to become better
advocates for the idea that we
in the federal government
can provide direct support
to these constituencies.
We need to make that a priority and
we need to keep talking about it.
So that's one thing
that we need to do.
We wanted to create a
clearing house of resources.
What does George have in his
institution that could be
of benefit to this community?
What does the Library
of Congress have?
I used to be at the
Department of Justice.
What do they have that could be
of benefit to these communities?
And again, when you think that
we have over 1,000 libraries
that cover every disciplinary
area you can imagine,
that list of resources can be
phenomenal if we could really get
that capture and then make it
available to these communities.
We also wanted to work with
American Indian communities in areas
like preservation,
digitization, cataloging.
I recently went to the ATALM
conference and there's a great deal
of interest among the
Native communities
about preserving their own cultures.
I mean, that just makes sense,
preserving their own language,
their own artifacts,
their own culture,
and so for them preservation,
digitization where possible
or necessary, cataloging comes
extremely important to them
as they really strive to ensure
that their culture remains
alive for generations to come.
And so that's another area where we
could really help these communities.
Training opportunities.
Well, look around you.
We've got a room full of cameras.
We could use the same technology
to work with those communities.
You know, we're already
out broadcasting,
we could certainly tailor
some training efforts.
In fact, like let's work on that.
I like this idea.
It just dawned on me.
We should do a series of
webinars targeted primarily
to the tribal colleges
and universities.
Maybe we could do that together?
That's UIMLS [laughing].
In case you're wondering
who I'm pointing at,
it's the IMLS people, and Gary, you-
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
Sure. No, no sometimes I just have
an idea and I have to just say it
to see how it sounds, but
I think we could do that.
We do lots of training anyway,
why couldn't we expand that
and really think about
how to move this training
out to the Native communities?
And also promote existing
federal resources and legal
and STEM knowledge collection of
value to America Indian libraries.
STEM is the rage, and of
course, we know the libraries,
as Gary has told us, are
under-funded, under-staffed.
There are weakened resources.
So what if we could bring the
power of these 1500 libraries
to those libraries in terms of STEM?
How remarkable would that be?
And later, you'll be hearing
about the legal resources
because we have Yolanda Goldberg
here from the Law Library
who is doing tremendous
work with her colleagues
to create a law portal
for Native American Law,
so we'll be paying a little bit more
attention to that this afternoon.
And that's really what I
have to say, so let me,
again let me just reiterate, not
to put too fine a point on it,
federal libraries represent
the largest collection
of intellectual resources
the world has ever seen.
When we gathered up bibliographic
records from other libraries
in the federal government,
we gathered 30 million
bibliographic records.
There is no library
system in the world
that has 30 million
bibliographic records.
How do we take that and how do we
take all the people that support
that and begin to really
make it available to some
of the people who need it the most?
And that's the challenge that
FEDLINK has in front of it.
So, thank you very much, and
I will now turn the floor
over to Mary Alice Ball, our
wonderful colleague from Institute
for Museum and Library Services.
Mary Alice, welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Alice Ball:
Good morning everyone.
I'm really delighted to be
here today to talk to you
about the Institute of
Museum and Libraries Services
and what we are doing to support
tribal libraries, whatever the level
of clienteles that they are serving.
I'll start just by saying we are one
of the three cultural
heritage agencies
within the federal government.
The National Endowment for
the Arts, National Endowment
for the Humanities are
better known than IMLS,
and I would like to say we are
the little engine that could.
We really try to make
a difference and I feel
like we are making a
difference on tribal lands.
But before I go there, I wanted to
mention that related to the work
that we are doing, and this both
on the library side in the Office
of Library Services and on
the museum side in the Office
of Museum Services and in our Policy
Research and Evaluation Department
where we are putting survey
research out all the time.
We have, within OLS
Library Services,
we have 2 strategic
priorities, and when Blaine,
Gary and George were talking, I
thought how I think these are things
that people might want
to know about.
We have 2 priorities, 1 being
the National Digital Platform
and the other being Learning in
Libraries, which includes a STEM,
but particularly National Digital
Platform, what we are doing
from our grant making
is funding initiatives
that will provide the
broadest range of resources,
whatever format those are in,
and do it in a way that is free
or really open, open access.
And so we've funded projects
with the Digital Public Library
of America, with Internet Archive,
with Hotte [phonetic] Trust,
with many academic institutions,
and I'll talk about them
a little bit at the end.
But I thought those are things I
encourage you to go to our website,
to imls.gov, and look at
our grant opportunities.
You can search awarded grants and
sometimes that's a good way to start
if you're not sure of what type of
idea you should come to us with.
It can help to read through
what we have funded already.
I have my email address on here,
so if you do have questions,
I'm thinking about folks that are
out there in cyberspace today,
please feel free to drop me a line.
So I thought I would
start by talking
about our Native American
Library Services basic grants.
These are non competitive
grants and they're designed
to support existing library
operations and really
to support those core library
services and collections
and there is a broad, we interpret
those core services very broadly,
and so it might be for building
a collection of resources
for young children, you know
pre-k literacy types of things,
or it could be elder
resources, working with elders,
and we funded things with programs
where teens are working with elders,
so there is a wide range,
but it can also go to things
like a dehumidifier,
book shelves, tables,
we interpret this very
broadly, it is a small grant,
so this one year grant is $6,000.00
and you can get an extra $1,000.00
for an educational option, and
that is education or assessment.
So someone can use it to go to
a conference, they can use it
to hire a consultant
to work with them.
There is no cost share required
for this and it is available
to any federally recognized tribe,
or Native/Alaskan village
or corporation.
We fund roughly, I think, somewhere
around 220-240 federally
recognized tribes right now
out of possible 567.
We are waiting, I'm looking forward
to talking to the representative
from the Pulmonkee
Tribe later today,
because we can start
funding them too.
We also have a Native American
Library Services Enhancement Grant,
and so this is really to push
out, be more initiative in terms
of the services, the programming
that these libraries are doing.
It can be about workforce
development, anything people come
to us with, language revitalization
, digital literacy skills,
cultural heritage preservation.
Again, for tribes that are so
challenged by circumstances
of society around them, this
funding can be really critical.
To help them, we've got a lot of
people right now that are working
on preserving their language, and
they come to us, and you know,
they've got 5 speakers of the
language, and they're worried
because they know that they
could disappear quickly,
so we see the urgency of
this funding for tribes.
Again, it's relatively
small compared some
of our other grant programs, because
there's a ceiling of $150,000.00
and that's up to 2 years,
although it could just be a year.
Again, cost share is not required.
>> I request to read the bottom of
that previous slide [inaudible].
>> Mary Alice Ball: It is cut off.
Again, this, it talks
about eligibility,
and if you go to our website, you
can find the full details there
of eligibility, but any federally
recognized tribe or Alaska village
or corporation is eligible to apply.
Thank you.
We have our 2015 fiscal year
budget was just over $3,000,800.00.
We have requested $4,000,000.00
in our 2016 budget,
so we'll see how that works out.
But if we look at how it's divided
down, there is just one bucket
of money, and due to the forethought
of Senator Daniel Inouye,
there is a percentage, and it
comes out to right now roughly just
over $550,000.00 for
Native Hawaiians grants,
and that usually comes
out to be maybe somewhere
of the range to 3-5 grantees.
Our Native American basic
grants, it's noncompetitive
as I said earlier, everybody
gets a piece, it just depends
on how many tribes apply.
This last year, it came out
to roughly $1,400,000.00
for 220 grantees, and
then the leftover,
the remainder of that
funding is what we use
to fund the Native American
Enhancement Awards, and last year,
that turned out to be $1,800,000.00.
It generally, we fund
somewhere in the range of 10
to 15 grants with that funding.
We also and I think it's something
that I'm proudest of for the agency,
that we move beyond the
funding that's designated
for tribal libraries,
to fund other sources
from our National Leadership
Grant program
and from the Laura Bush 21st
Century Librarian program.
The second has to deal with
education and recruitment
into the profession,
national leadership grant,
programs of national
scope more innovative.
So we fund the Association of Tribal
Archives Libraries and Museums.
I think many of you went to the
ATALM conference this last September
and we fund the workshops
that we see as really critical
for the continuing education
and professional development
of tribal librarians, who
as we've heard, ya know,
it may be a one person shop.
We do allow them to use their
funds to hire substitutes,
so that the library
doesn't have to close
when they go off to a conference.
We fund scholarships.
Susan Feller, the CEO of ATALM
is very convincing, so each year,
she comes back and says, well,
we need a little bit more,
can you give us a supplement
because we need more scholarships?
And this year, I think we
gave an extra $75,000.00.
In the world of grant making,
$75,000.00 is chump change,
but for that tribal librarian
who wants to come from, you know,
upper Montana or something,
it's huge.
We also funded and will fund
a neck of subsequent survey,
but a study that ATALM
did of digital inclusion
in Native communities and this
is a report, you can find it
on the ATALM website,
it was huge I would say
in informing the Federal
Communications Commission
and the Department of Commerce's
National Telecommunications
Information Administration, about
the situation on tribal lands
in terms of broadband access,
adoption, digital literacy skills,
all these issues around
digital inclusion.
We have also funded
a project that came
out of Washington State University
called Mukatu [assumed spelling]
which is an indigenous New Zealand
or Australian indigenous word.
We funded them to the
tune of $1,400.00 dollars,
and we funded the development
of this open source platform,
that there are a lot of, or
certainly we don't see a paucity
of cultural heritage tools that
are out there, but this is a tool
that was made for ingenious
communities and so it understands
that not everything needs to
be made publically accessible,
that Native nations have the
need and the right to say we want
to restrict these materials,
only a man should see them,
only a woman should see them,
only and elder should see them,
only a tribal member, regardless
where that tribal member may be
because we know so many tribal
members have to go to other places
to get jobs, but if they are
in LA, they should be able
to access a collection that
is back home in Oklahoma,
and we funded quite a bit
of training around this,
we're continuing, there's a
second cohort of 6 tribes,
2 people from each tribe
that is just being formed,
and these people will
learn how to use the tools,
and some are already coming to us
to get funding for the technology.
And I should also say they're
developing a kit that will be used
and to help train and
support people in this.
This last year, we gave a
grant to Amherst College
and it was a collaborative
planning grant.
They have quite a few
partners, but we do know,
and I think they are
coming to terms with maybe
because they do have Native
American faculty members
who are pushing Amherst to think
beyond just having these holdings
and keeping them within
their own doors.
They want to create a digital atlas
of Native American
Intellectual Traditions
and build a national platform
so that all people could see
these important valuable resources
that are held, and they will be
able to see them wherever they are.
Okay, I'm moving back up because
I wrote notes, on the bottom,
because I forgot to put on this
slide that IMLS also has done a lot
of work, at the behest of the
administration in different areas,
and I think none that I
feel is compelled to talk
about as our participation
in the President's
Broadband Opportunity Council.
We have highlighted
actions that we will take.
We also see that what other agencies
are doing and we've tried to,
how shall I say, like insert
ourselves into their initiatives
so that we can disseminate
what they are doing
to libraries around the country.
One of those, some of
my colleagues here know,
my proudest accomplishment as being
one of the IMLS representatives
on that council was the insertion
of a comma in the word libraries
into a program that General
Services Administration is doing
with they've refurbished computers,
they have a program called Computers
For Learning and so when they had
written up the eligible entities,
it was educational institutions
or other educational-related
organizations and think of those
of us in the Federal Government know
that if it isn't clearly
spelled out, then it's in doubt,
and so now we have
inserted in their libraries
that libraries will be able and
eligible to get this equipment.
The Broadband Opportunity
Council came
out with a report a
couple of months ago.
You can find it by Googling White
House Broadband Opportunity Council
Report and I would
encourage you to read it.
It has a number of things.
I'm concerned about
time so I won't go on.
Oh, I have time, okay,
then I will go on.
IMLS has funded 2 things that we're
doing that are already underway,
one is a grant to Internet2 and some
of you may know Internet2
is a network, an association
of these largest research
and education networks,
and we have funded Internet2 to
pilot a program where research
and education networks will
work with Tribal and rural,
so rural libraries that are not
necessarily tribal libraries,
and I think it's going to be in 5
states, working with the Research
and Education Network in
those states and to go out
and develop a network
assessment tool.
I mean on tribal lands,
broadband itself is, you know,
in an abysmal state and we
are trying to improve that,
but we do know that even in
institutions that have broadband,
quite often their networks aren't
configured properly enough for them
to get what they're paying for.
And so the development of
this sort of tool we hope will
to enable people to get people
higher speed broadband access
and then be able to access
richer resources online.
We are also funding a
grant to the Chief Officers
of State Library Associations
and I should say that both
of these grants are done
in partnership with ATALM
and with the American
Library Association,
as I look at 2 representatives
from it here.
But the COSLA proposal and
it is underway, yesterday,
Marijke Visser had a blog post
about the E-rate Clearinghouse
that has been done by COSLA and
the Georgia Public Library Service
and E-rate is something
we are trying
to get more tribal libraries to use.
Some our eligible and yet
they may not think they are,
so it's definitely
worth investigating.
There is also a training
component and a cross state survey
that is being done, related to
E-rate and E-rate training needs.
So those were our contributions
to the report
where we weren't piggybacking
on other agencies like GSA.
Last week, the President held
a tribal leadership summit,
and then on Friday morning,
at the very end of that,
the Broadband Opportunity
Council had a listening session
where we listened to tribal Leaders
talk about the state broadband
out of Native Nations and what
could be done, what should be done,
and challenging us as the Federal
Administration to make a difference.
And I think that's
all I have to say.
Any questions, Gary?
>> Yeah, [inaudible].
>> Mary Alice Ball: Oh, yes, sorry,
because we do, we fund a lot,
so we also fund and it's Mary
Ann Hanson if you're listening,
I'll give a shout out to you, the
Tribal College Leadership Institute.
That we funded for many,
many years out in Bozeman
and brings tribal librarians
together,
tribal college librarians
together for leadership training.
Any other things that I forgotten?
Anybody can think of?
Another question?
>> Next session.
>> Mary Alice Ball: Okay,
we're moving right along.
>> George Franchois: I think we're
going to go ahead and get started
with this afternoon's programming.
My name is George Franchois.
I'm the director of the Department
of the Interior Library, and once,
again I want to welcome everyone
here to the Library of Congress
for our program this afternoon.
Our first program is American
Indians in the federal city
and regional history
and we are very pleased
to have Joseph Genetin-Pilawe
here with us this afternoon
to talk a little bit about
the about how Washington D.C.,
about American Indians
in Washington D.C.
and how American Indians
contributed to the development
of this great nation's capital.
So with that, Joseph.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Genetin-Pilawe: Hi
everyone, thanks for being here.
Before I say anything else,
it's important to acknowledge
that as we think and talk together,
we do so not only in the Library
of Congress but on the homelands
of the Piscataway Nation
and a broader region that includes
the homelands of the Pamunkey
and Monacan Nations as well.
It's an absolute pleasure
to be here.
I'm excited to be on a panel
with Gabby, Tara, Ben, and Karen.
I'm excited to hear them talk
about their work in activism.
I'm up first today because I
had the honor of being selected
as a John W. Kluge Center fellow
last year to conduct research
on my current book project which is
a study of the indigenous histories
of Washington DC that I'm
calling the Indian's captial city.
The Kluge Center supports humanity
scholars from around the world
and brings them together to
stimulate and energize one another,
to distill wisdom from the
Library of Congress' rich resources
and to interact with policy
makers and the public.
My time at the center was amazing.
I think it's important to point
out as well that over the course
of its 15-year history, the
Kluge Center has supported dozens
of scholars working in the fields
of Native American and
indigenous studies.
The center has been doing important
work in this direction and it,
as well as the librarians,
archivists,
and collection specialists here,
have been supporting the field
in really important ways.
So with the time that I have, I
would like to give a brief overview
of the project that I worked on
as a Kluge fellow and I would
like to start with a brief
antidote but one more caveat.
My work focuses primarily on native
diplomats who visited the city
from outside this region.
Our next speaker, Gabby Tayac, will
talk more about the long, deep,
and rich indigenous histories
of the Potomac and Chesapeake.
So here we go.
On Saturday, September 29th,
1837, a group of Lakota, Iowa Sac
and Fox men and women sat
in the National Theater
in Washington watching a romantic
opera called The Mountain Sylph.
They found themselves, as many
as the other audience
members likely did,
mesmerized watching the prima donna,
a soprano named Annette Nelson
portray the opera's lead character.
So impressed by her agility and
beauty "appearing and vanishing
with the rapidity that reminded
them of the fleetness of the deer
in their native hunting
grounds" wrote one newspaper.
The men saluted her right in
the middle of the performance.
In a show of respect,
[inaudible] man through
and Eagle-feathered cap at her feet.
Pokana [assumed spelling],
a Sac Chief offered his cap
as well while Tokaka
[assumed spelling],
another Yankton gave her
his white wolf-skinned robe.
This was completely unplanned
but the actress displaying poise
and grace thanked the man saying
she would "ever regard them
as friends and brethren".
Then, she gave each
man an ostrich plume
from her costume as a return gift.
To a modern audience, this
appears to be quite unexpected,
not just a breach of proper
etiquette but actual presence
of native folks in an 1830's
Washington Theater enjoying an opera
seems almost unbelievable.
But how unexpected was it though?
Despite what some might think,
across the 19th Century and beyond,
hundreds and thousands of
native people travel to
and lived in the capital.
In reality, seems like this
one happened regularly.
Well every Indian nation has
its own unique and rich history,
one thing that unites all of these
experiences is a relationship
to the Federal Government
and Washington D.C. These episodes
appear unexpected to us today
because of a perceived incongruity
of native people in urban spaces.
In other words, the idea that
Indians and cities cannot coexist
and that one must necessarily
be eclipsed by the other.
This unexpectedness is especially
rooted in Washington D.C. due
to the creation of a commemorative
landscape here centered
in the architecture of
federal buildings but dispersed
around the city as well and here are
a few images of the art and artwork.
This picture isn't very clear
but you can see there are 2
statue groups that used to stand
on the east front of
the Capital Building.
Every president from
the early 19th Century
until the 1950's was inaugurated
between these 2 statue groups.
This is actually Lincoln's
second inauguration.
There's a close up of one
of them, the Discovery.
Here is the other called the Rescue.
These statues were ultimately
removed in the 1950's
in large part due to a
campaign lead by a native woman.
She was Omahan named Ledameyer Smart
[assumed spelling] who wrote dozens
and dozens of letters,
garnered support
of groups across the country.
They are ultimately lifted off
the cheap blocks and are now
in a warehouse at Fort Meade.
I'll leave it back on
there for a second, sorry.
So the art and architecture
of the federal building iterated
spatially notions of pacification
of a conquest completed
and of vanishing Indians.
My project argues that unlike
the subjects of this art
and architecture though, indigenous
visitors and inhabitants engaged
with non-native individuals and
the symbols of settler society
in Washington carved out their
own spaces within it and claimed
or reclaimed ownership of the place.
In doing so, indigenous people
shaped how the capital came
to understand itself
ultimately as an imperial center;
they were it's looking glass.
Washington after all and especially
in the early 19th century was
a provincial local place first
and foremost.
It had to learn, it
became a national city,
and then an imperial capital,
and later a global metropolis.
I'd like to finish my remarks
today with one more anecdote
that illustrates the layered
histories of indigenous experiences
as well as representations of
indigenous peoples in the capital,
and this one requires a
little local knowledge.
I'll be talking about the Dumbarton
Bridge or as it's known commonly
in the city, the Buffalo Bridge.
So in 2010, a fellow historian
and I were in the city.
One day, I went to the
archives and he went for a run.
When I returned to our
room later that day,
he asked if I knew
anything about a bridge
that had 4 gigantic buffalos on it.
Well, I'd only just begun
the research for this project
and I knew nothing
about this bridge.
I went back to the archives
the next day and he took a walk
around the city with his camera.
When I returned the second
evening, he showed me pictures
of the 4 buffallos as well
as 56 Indian head busts
that adorn the bridge.
Native people are everywhere in this
city he said, I had to learn more.
Here is an aerial shot
of the bridge.
Those Indian head busts that I'm
talking about are at the bottom
of each one of the smaller
arches, on the upper level there,
and it's the same person's
head over and over again.
I'll get to that in a second.
Georgetown was formed in 1751, I'll
go back to this map for a second,
decades before the District of
Columbia or the city of Washington,
and here you can see it on
the left-hand side of the map.
But in 1871, it was merged with
Washington, residential sprawl
over the next few decades
and encouraged city leaders
to provide a connecting artery
between North Georgetown
and Dupont Circle.
There was one problem.
It's pretty obvious in this
map and that is the rock creek
and the surrounding heights
that separated the 2 spaces.
The initial plan involved filling
the gorge with like boulders
and junk and things like that.
This was a horrible idea,
but the McMillan Commission
which was a senate committee
whose report continues
to guide capital development to this
day, selected Q Street as a location
for a new bridge instead
of filling in the gorge,
despite the fact though,
interestingly,
that Q Street in Georgetown
is 185 feet South of Q Street
in Dupont Circle, so the
bridge would need to be curved
and also it came to a dead end
at the historic Dumbarton Mansion
which would need to be lifted
up and moved about 100 feet.
So there you can see the curved
bridge and the Dumbarton Mansion.
Glen Brown, who was a proponent
of the McMillan Commission
and the City Beautiful Architecture
Movement, designed the bridge
and the structures features several
City Beautiful design elements.
For example, you see
neoclassical arches, corbel arches,
piers and pillars that
reminiscent of Roman Acquadox.
More obviously, its scale
and style were typical
of the City Beautiful aesthetic.
After all, they couldn't
simply built a functional
and utilitarian bridge.
The use of the Buffalo and
Indian head iconography,
the most distinctive elements of
the bridge, also connect it's design
to the City Beautiful movement.
The movement got its start in 1893
at Chicago's Columbian Exposition.
Unlike the World's Fair itself, the
bridge reflects a certain nostalgia
for a vanishing frontier.
In fact, in an interview,
Glen Brown noted, we quote,
"naturally determine to give the
carvings of the other portions
of the structure an
American character".
In this formulation, it makes sense
that the designers chose what seems
to be a generic Plains motif and
I'm sorry that I don't have closer,
up close pictures of the Reliefs
and Buffaloes, but buffaloes
and an Indian head with prominent
cheekbones and a war bonnet,
these images are mobile and
serve as free-floating stand ins
for a constellation of ideas
that simultaneously express
and excuse settler
anxieties and guilt.
The problem of course is that
these images aren't free floating
and that histories aren't metaphors.
There's another way to think of this
bridge and it's iconography though
and the busts that sit below each
pillar, these were actually modeled
from the life mask of a man named
Matho Wanahtake or Kicking Bear.
He was a Minneconjou Lakota leader
who played a significant role
in bringing the Ghost Dance
movement to the Plains.
In the 1890's, Kicking Bear traveled
to Washington to advocate on behalf
of the Lakota at the
Office of Indian Affairs.
This was just following
Wounded Knee.
Simultaneous to Kicking
Bear's visit, archaeologist,
William Henry Holmes, who worked for
the Smithsonian Bureau of Ethnology
and then served as head
curator of Anthropology
at the US National Museum,
conducted significant excavations
around Washington.
One of the sites his team
investigated thoroughly was the
Dumbarton Heights,
an area just below
where the bridge would
ultimately be built.
There, Holmes and his team found
an important stone quarry site
where Piscataway people
for generations excavated
materials and made stone tools.
So here it is, all
wrapped up in one site.
A bridge built in the nineteen-teens
using cutting-edge architectural
technology and trendy design
elements that are meant
to memorialize and
celebrate a generic
and supposedly bygone American past.
But the bust the designer used
actually commemorates a native
leader who challenged US colonialism
spiritually and militarily
on the Plains as well as
politically and diplomatically
in the city itself, and
they built it atop land
that has been significant to
indigenous and inhabitants
since time and memorial, ancient,
modern, vanishing, and ever present.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now I'd like to invite Gabby
Tayac from the National Museum
of the American Indian
up to speak next.
[ Silence ]
>> Gabrielle Tayac: Hi.
I'd really like to greet all
of you and a special greeting
to my relatives who are here
from the other areas of the bay
and a little bit further
on the mountains.
Our people are also Algonkian
people so greeting to Tara as well,
and to all of you who are in this
place that we know as the capital.
Like to take you to another capital.
I'd like you to imagine going
down the Potomac River a bit today
to the first capital of these lands.
There's a unmarked field and
there lies our holiest place.
It's a placed called Moyaone.
It's a sacred place.
It's right on the Potomac and
it sits facing Mount Vernon.
It just looks like a field
and now it's a National Park.
There are no signs on it.
It's on the National Historic
Register, but there are people
who are just walking their dogs
there every day, playing Frisbee,
going by, and then
wondering what they're seeing
when they see a sweat
lodge that's there.
They see a red cedar
tree that's there.
They see a photograph of a man named
Turkey Tayac who is my grandfather
who is there, and they see
offerings, and they see reflections,
and they see memories, and traces
of a place that are recorded back
in time for at least 10,000
years or maybe from the time
that Sky Woman came and landed on a
turtle's back or maybe from the time
that the people sprung
out from the hairs
of the deer and populated the land.
So this is very indicative in this
place Moyaone, which is in Accokeek,
Maryland, of how you are fully and
completely surrounded and enveloped
by a very long-term
indigenous history
that is almost entirely
erased from our consciousness.
When you go to the Anacostia,
the Anacostians where part
of our chiefdom, part of
the Piscataway chiefdom,
their name was the Nacotchtank
and it's anglicized and Latinized
to sound like Anacostia, but all
we know is there's the river,
there's the Potomac or Patawomeck
which is also a group of people.
There are places like
Madwomen [assumed spelling]
and Zakia [assumed
spelling] all sorts
of words that we see on the land.
And this landscaping itself is
formed by the Chesapeake Bay
and the Chesapeake meaning great
shellfish bay, which is the mother
of waters, which has lungs that are
formed by vast amounts historically
of oysters, and oyster shells,
which filter the water pristinely,
that have been entirely taken out.
So in this interconnected beautiful
system that was first mapped
for Europeans by John Smith
in 1608, and he didn't look
like Disney movie guy, okay,
and he didn't marry Pocahontas
and Pocahontas was a lot cooler than
you would ever, ever imagine her
to be actually and I've had
a love-hate relationship
with Pocahontas for my entire life
and I've come to respect
her greatly.
So our people were organized
here with Point of Rocks,
the quarries that you speak, about
being kind of on the edges of it,
going into what we
call the fall line,
all the way down to
Point Lookout which is
where the Yaocomico people were.
And in the heart of it is at this
place that I'm describing to you,
just about 15 miles south of the DC
line in Pascoti National Park today.
The way it was organized
was we had a central chief
who was actually called the
Tayac, and my sir name is part
of an acknowledgement and
an honor to my grandfather
who really revitalized that
role and decided to take
that sir name legally because of
the activism that was happening here
in the late 1960's and 1970's but
he started using it in the 1930's.
And so the Tayac was somebody
who was able to bring in people
from over a dozen towns, each
with a leader called a werowance
who could also be a woman who
was known as a wereowance qua,
advised by wisos or peace chiefs,
[inaudible] who were considered
to be, by an Engilsh
system, war chiefs,
but in fact these were statesman
and that word is linked to the word
that we now think about as caucus,
so in terms of a negotiation.
And that is where we have
this system operating
in what is often known or thought
about prehistory but its history.
And so about 13 generations before
the arc and the dove came in 1634,
there was a man on the eastern
shore of Maryland named [inaudible]
and he broke off from the Nanticoke
and established this governmental
polity here on the Western shore
and started to basically
look at, it's kind of,
not really a federal system but
not too far out from that in terms
of centralized area
of power at Moyaone,
a town that then would
receive tribute and interaction
and communication from
around the region
and they would bring people
together through ceremony.
So there's a really, there's a very
long history and the question is,
why do we not know
anything about this capital?
Why doesn't anybody here
speak Piscataway anymore?
And that's wrapped up, you
know if you really want
to know what the language is and
what the history is and you want
to know well what happened to
people, you just have to kind
of see all of these things that have
been built up over the landscape.
So the history here, I'm just
going to wrap up because 7 minutes
to take you through 400 years is
[laughing] especially because,
you know, we were chatting a
little bit and I was thinking,
there's been a lot of silencing and
a lot of times we do like to take
up our time when we need to
speak, but the issue is is that,
that question of what happened and
why you don't know and why you have
to dig so hard in the primary
records and then also look
through oral histories are
extremely essential and so
that is what I would want to
talk about because the, you know,
we'll talk more but really
this idea of the merging
of the what has remained
in terms of oral account,
matching it up with what's
available in the documentary account
because I started my work by
listening around the kitchen table,
by being involved revitalization
of the people
and then deciding I wanted
to take an academic track
to really figure it out and
bring those voices forward.
So that work, it's long, hard
work and it's a puzzle over time
and there are very unique
things about this region
that follow the patterns
that we see for native people
across the continent
but also get wrapped
up in something particularly
vicious and pervasive
on the Atlantic Seaboard and
that has to do with race policy.
So there's a lot of intertwining
here and we'll have a chance
to talk more, but in the
meantime just to kind
of reorient your head space to how
to long this history has been going.
It's not been since 1800
and it's not been since 1750
and it's not been since 1607.
It's been for a very long time.
So with that I would
like to introduce Tara
who will bring is right
up into the present.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Tara Houska: My name is Tara
Houska My Indian name is the woman
who finishes this song and I'm Bear
Clan from Couchiching First Nation.
So like Gabby said, I think I'm
here to represent the present.
My perspective is of one of many
Native Americans who graduate
and move to Washington D.C.
to go represent our nations.
All of Indian law is federal.
It's federal law and tribal
law and so this is kind
of where everything is decided.
This is where all the policies
that affect our people are decided.
These are the congressional
members that control our fates,
really, in a lot of ways.
So, it's a really different
experience being in D.C., for sure.
Native Americans are very
community based and I think one
of the first things you do is
find your fellow Native Americans
and kind of like, hey
guys, I'm here, you know.
It's kind of changing
group because there's a lot
of transplants coming in and out.
But that is pretty much the first
thing you do when you get here
and I think it's important to
understand kind of like how it feels
to be a Native American in
D.C. and to work and live
in these spaces beyond just like not
having, you know, your own community
and being with your own people
and your land and all of that.
I think one of the very hard
things, at least for me,
and that's also why I
became connected to Joe,
was moving here and
seeing the Mascot.
That was really kind of a
shocking experience for me.
In Minnesota where I'm from,
we actually banned Native
Mascots back in 1992.
So it just wasn't an issue
and something I never really thought
about, and you know, I was standing
in Subway, I think a
couple weeks into work.
I work at a Native
American Law Firm.
We [inaudible] American Law and I
was standing in Subway and the guy
in front of me was wearing a hat
and the guy behind me
was wearing a jersey,
and the employees are
all wearing pins
because there was some
promotion going on
and that name was everywhere
and that head was everywhere.
And I was shocked, kind
of floored at that moment,
thinking about what it would be like
to be a Native American child here,
and to grow up here and to
see that and just, you know,
know that that's what
people really think of you.
Today I'm wearing Moccasins.
It's Rock your Mocs day
and I've already on the way
in here got a lot really
strange looks, right,
because I think it's kind of the
issue of the mascot and just kind
of the overall sense
of Native Americans is
that we are vanished people.
And so when they see something
like this, it kind of shocks them,
like oh my goodness, other
Native Americans that are here
and they exist and they are
in Washington D.C. working
and living in these places?
Yes. Absolutely.
We're just aren't walking around in
headdresses and painting our faces
which is what they expect.
So that's kind of-- that really
sprung me towards doing a lot
of social justice work and
becoming heavily involved
with the mascot movement and you
know kind of doing what I can
from D.C. to help the representation
of Native Americans across the board
and how we're portrayed in the
media but also here in D.C. I mean,
it is something that, in the work I
do, I go and lobby on Capital Hill,
and you know we're pushing for
we need money for a hospital,
we need the right the prosecute
individuals on the reservation.
These are things that we don't have.
They are fundamental things we don't
have, and it's hard when you walk
in knowing that, you know,
the congressional number,
depending on how many tribes
they have in their region,
or maybe they don't have
any, is going to kind
of have this idea already in
their heads before they see you,
that you are this old static
character and that you know,
well we don't really want to
give the Indians, you know,
the right to do these things
because they're not civilized.
Right. I mean those are real impacts
that really actually really do
affect us, and it also, you know,
I think the more important thing is
really about children but just today
or this last week actually,
I had the honor of speaking
with Bernie Sanders as he
was introducing a bill.
I do a lot of environmental justice
work as well, and it was funny
because that morning, he
doesn't have any tribes,
any federally recognized
tribes in Vermont,
and that very morning he had
actually met with the delegation
of Apache people from Oak Flat.
Oak Flat is a sacred place
that was actually given
by the federal government
to [inaudible] operation
and it's about to be destroyed.
That is our congress.
So he met with them, and you
know, to a guy that has no idea
about tribes, I think it was
kind of really shocking to him
and really inspired and moved
him, and then when he was walking
out towards me I could just
see his eyebrows go up, like,
oh my goodness, another Indian.
Like. And I'm like,
we're everywhere,
you know, we're everywhere.
And so I think that you know
as researchers and, you know,
I've been to the Library
of Congress several times.
I mean a lot of the work we do
in federal Indian law is
hundreds of years old, right?
I mean federal Indian law is a
moving body of law but it's also,
I mean you're going
to be citing a case
from 1800 every now
and again at a brief.
It's a really strange area of law,
but you also get to learn a lot
of history along the way.
So I think it's very important to be
cognizant that we are modern people
and that we are here, that
representation really does matter,
that we should be doing everything
we possibly can to educate people
about the tribal nations
that are here and the ones
that have been coming here for, I
mean since the beginning, right?
The very, very beginning.
There have been delegations
of tribal leaders
and the National Congress
of American Indians is here
in Washington D.C. I am one of many,
many people that comes out here
as an attorney, as a staffer,
as every kind of possible job
that you can imagine, that's
what we are doing out here
in Washington D.C. So I think
it's very important for all of you
to at least try to make
people aware of that.
Everyone that I have worked
here with at the Library
of Congress has been fantastic
as far as doing research
and understanding and I've
gotten to hold treaties
and all these really
great things, right.
And you know I just encourage
you to do that and thank you,
and it's a little awkward
not being on the panel
and talking to y'all like this.
Hopefully the talk is much better.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Tara Houska: Oh!
Oh, and I'm introducing,
this is Karenne.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Karenne Wood: I want to
welcome you to our homeland.
I'm a Monacan person.
My name is Karenne Wood.
I direct Virginia Indian Programs
at the Virginia Foundation
for the Humanities.
So in my professional life, I'm a
public historian and an educator.
All about filling the gaps between
the past and the present and so much
of that story that's been left out
and understanding what's
happened to our people.
In my not so professional life
I'm a poet, so I started out life
as a writer and I've
written two books of poetry.
The second one comes out this spring
called, "Weaving the Boundary"
and it focuses too on American
Indian History because there are
so many gaps in the larger
story beyond Virginia
that many people don't know about.
What we do know is
that people have been
in what we call Virginia
for 18,000 years.
When I was in school,
it was presented
as an absolute scientific
fact that native people came
across the Bering Strait's
land bridge carrying spears
and hunting Mastodons and wearing
fur coats and that happened ten
to twelve thousand years ago.
So archeologists have had to now
call into question everything
that they've told us
about how we got here.
And I found it very interesting
and comforting to realize
that there are native stories in
our area that reference giant bears
and giant beavers and giant
bison and everybody said,
oh isn't that cute,
those native legends.
And then archeologists
found evidence
of those creatures in Virginia.
So this is the kind of information
that I get to encounter every day,
and I didn't' start
out as a researcher.
I started out as a tribal historian.
In order to collect the history
that we didn't have about our story,
I had to become a researcher and so
my friend and I, my tribal friend,
Diane Shields and I,
for about ten years dug
into all the records we could find
and began to reconstruct that story
so that we could develop a
petition that would go to the Bureau
of Indian Affairs documenting
our case for federal recognition.
What we now have is a historical
chronology that traces the movements
of our people and the
places in which they appear
in historical records, and what
I've learned in that process is
that people who write
history have agendas.
It's not absolute objective facts in
the way that we were told in school.
And I've also learned that whenever
you tell a story you decide what
to leave in and what to leave out,
and in our case an awful
lot has been left out.
Including most of the voices,
I'd like to say maybe 75 percent
of the people who participated
in history, all of the women,
all the people of color,
all the poor white people.
Their voices were not present in the
stories that I learned in school.
When we took our elders to
Virginia Tech to for the first time
to show them what kind of
higher education was possible
for their grandkids,
some of them cried
because it wasn't even conceivable
that they could attend
a university like that.
Most of them went to a one room
school first through seventh grade
up until 1963 in Virginia
and if they wanted to go
to high school they had to go to
a federal Indian boarding school
in Muskogee, Oklahoma, which
meant they left in September
and didn't see their
families again until June
because they couldn't
come home for Christmas.
They didn't know their
brothers and sisters.
They really didn't have the
relationship with their parents
that most of us have enjoyed
without even thinking about it.
So we have learned these things
about ourselves by studying
that history and studying the
accounts of people like John Smith.
I love John Smith's map.
It's remarkably accurate
considering how little
of that area he actually visited.
So what that that tells me is
that there were Native people,
informants anthropologists called
them, [laughing] who were able
to translate for him the
geography of what's now Virginia
on a flat piece of paper, right.
Well, this is the way
the rivers go and so on.
And what I've also realized
in looking at these records is
that native history is inscribed
on the place by the place names
that we have given certain areas,
and they are many Native place names
in the coastal plain where
the Piscataway people
and other [inaudible]
speakers lived, or live,
because they did a lot of
interacting with the colonial people
who did the documenting,
not so much with my people.
We seem to want to avoid
contact, probably for good reason.
Maybe we've heard some
stories about what happened
when those explorers showed up.
We called them people faces
whose faces grew hair upside
down [laughing], but there's
not a lot of documentation
about the Monacan's and what
happened to them in comparison
to the Powhatan people and they
aren't so many place names,
so if you look at the
creeks and rivers
up in our area you don't' see our
language represented in the way
that you do, you know Piscataway
and Patuxent and Potomac,
and I mean almost every
river up the [inaudible].
You know, the rivers took the names
from the people who lived there,
and we don't necessarily know what
the native people called them,
but I live in my house fifteen
minutes from the headquarters
of the Monacan nation
during colonial times.
Where the [inaudible] and
James Rivers come together.
So I'm home and I like it there.
In any event, putting all of this
story together has just convinced me
that they are so many ways
to tell about the past
and history is only
one of those ways.
Native people had broad
and beautiful ways
of understanding the world
and their place in it,
and enough of those traces
remain to us that we can continue
to put ourselves in that web
and understand our
responsibilities as human beings.
Not as care takers, in an Adam
and Eve sense, but as relatives.
I think that is the most important
thing we fail to teach kids is how
to be a good relative, how to
be a good part of a community.
And native people know
how to still do that.
you know, it's not distinguishing
yourself as an individual.
And so when I came into the academy
I did it for a very specific reason.
Someone had said, Kareene Wood
is a self-styled historian,
because I didn't have a Ph.D.
that irritated me so I got one.
It took me quite a while.
It was also annoying when
people said I really admire you
for going back to school
at your age.
But I did it, not because
I wanted to change my job
but because I wanted the validation
to be able to say I'm as much
as an expert of my people's
story is somebody else is.
And when I did it, I didn't' come
in as an individual who is supposed
to come up with some exciting
concept or invent a new term
or we like to do that
in the academics.
You have to do something new and all
of your college looks at your work
and go rrrrrr and tear
you up, you know.
When I came in it was a whole
community of people on my shoulders
who were happy to tell me
if I was doing it wrong.
I had a responsibly to
tell the story in a way
that honors those ancestors and that
collectively it expands the story
that we know.
When the elders came to us they
said, you young people have
to get an education and
change what's in those books,
because we aren't the
people that they describe.
We are not savages, you know,
and they didn't see themselves
in those stories, so it is so
important to me to continue the work
that I do and to bring more
people into the mix to help us.
We have a lot of work to do.
And I'm honored to be part
of it to be able to do that.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ben Norman: Then yes,
my name is Ben Norman.
I come from Pamunkey Tribe
which is located in Virginia.
If you are familiar, there is the
York River that comes into Virginia
and it splits into two
rivers which is the Pamunkey
and the Manipeni Rivers, so there
on the left side where were located,
right around that Peninsula.
So thanks for having me here for all
of our co presenters it's
really great hearing from them
and also hearing language from them.
There's a lot of there's
some work being done recently
with our language and when a person
is participating that is Iancustla
and through some of his research,
he's actually found is the meaning
of Pamunkey which is crazy that we
don't actually know at this point.
But what he's found is that
it actually means place
where people sweat,
that's what it means.
It's a place where people come
to pray, is what that means,
it sounds kind of funny
but, yea it's the actual,
according to his research
that he's done,
and it means place
where peoples sweat.
It was a place that was very well
protected so I think that leaders
and individuals that needed to
come for you know maybe down time
and also a way to come pray.
So when I first heard of the topic
this discussion American Indians
in Federal City and Regional
History, I thought I kind of fit
into both of these ideas from
Pamunkey which is within this region
and moved here to come work
here, here at Washington D.C.
at the National Museum
of American Indians.
So it also made me also think
about people from my own families
that have come here to
D.C. for different reasons,
like my father Frank Badbee
I remember him telling me
about coming here 1678 for the
longest walk to help to know
to participate in the longest walk
and bring attention to treaty rights
and things that were going
on in the Native Communities.
it also made me think of my wife's
grandmother her name is Vilma Peters
she's from the Opononeo
Tono nations Oklahoma.
So I remember hearing,
always hearing stories
of her coming here she was a member
of the American Indian movement
and remember hearing
stories of her coming here
for D.C. for different occasions.
One of these stories
is in 1972 Vilma
and her youngest son traveled here
to D.C. again to bring attention
to standards of living back
at home, treaty rights,
during that trip things escalated
eventually as you may know took
over the BIA building, they
stayed there for seven days
and at her funeral a lot of her
things possessions were there
for people to come photos,
important things to her,
artwork that her grandchildren
had made,
there's even a really
awesome American Indian Jacket
that is hers, that was there.
Political pens things that she kept,
one that really stuck out to me,
it just said another
Indian for Decacus.
And also there was a book that
was there it looked like a journal
that was there on the table, at
first I didn't' want to read it.
I thought it was kind of an invasion
of her privacy, her journal,
I saw some other family
members reading it
so I thought I couldn't' resist.
I'll take a look at it, and
which I'm really glad I did.
It was a journal and it was
actually a journal of her times here
in Washington D.C. during that trip
and it was very detailed journal.
So detailed to where she stayed
all of the Taxi's that she rode in
and where they were picked up
where they were dropped off
and even the price of the Taxi,
it was very, very detailed.
So the end of the journal I thought
it was really interesting the
government and politicians were
really wanting them to leave
because they actually bought her
a plane ticket, her and her son,
to fly back to Oklahoma, and the
last journal entry she said her
and her son, which is name is Thomas
Whiteshirt he was seven years old
at the time at this trip,
they were actually in the air,
when she was writing the
journal entry, she was thinking
about the work they had done here,
the attention they have brought
to the issues here and she was
hopeful in this last entry,
and hopeful for the last generations
of Native children who would be
in a better situation because of
their work, so things like this kind
of every once in a while will
kind of rejuvenate me and the work
that we are doing at the museum,
trying to educate the public
so as you probably guess, we get
a lot of crazy questions at work.
99% of the time you know
and over feel really good
about what we're doing,
but sometimes you'll get people
just trying to argue and things
like that, and sometimes they
are kind of funny questions
like once we had a question of.
Why did the Indians follow the
buffalo was it for their milk?
That was real question from
an adult also, not a child.
Another one some of them are
kind of heartbreaking to read,
one I actually got from a
chaperone on a school tour was.
How many breeds are
American Indians are there?
Another one, this was one that I
jsut overheard two ladies were going
to the restroom and they were
the restroom was closed so one
of them said I wonder
why it's closed
and the other one said well you
know Indians really don't know
about plumbing.
So we have questions like
that, they really stick
with you especially early on when I
first started working at the museum,
stuck with me, came home
with me, thought about it,
now that I've been there for a
long time it doesn't' affect me
as much I just try to take these
moments as a learning opportunity
to work with the public,
and educate them.
And also fit into this because I'm
from Pumonkey currently may
know some of our situation
at the moment you may think
that we are Federally recognized
567 recognized tribe I think a lot
of people heard the news originally
that we were federally recognized
but not as people know that we were
challenged again, which was kind
of expected because these don't
even want to mention their names
who challenged us but
they are you know they are
in this for a different reason.
Some of the things that they
are challenging us on basically
if we are native Americans
and if our if we are a nation,
that still continues today
there both really ridiculous one
of the many amazing things about our
community because we have been some
of the first people to get basically
colonized so we have lost a lot
of our ways during this,
these hundreds of years
but our Government has always
continued still to this day,
you know, and never stopped.
We have minutes recorded
of our meetings going back
over a hundred years so these, these
questions you know of our Indianist
or our government continuing
are ridiculous
so through this independent
board that's going
to review this hopefully the process
will go quickly and we'll be able
to continue this really important
work that needs to be done
in our community and for
our future generations.
I have a son that's two and
one that's on the way right now
in January, so I'm
really excited for them
and the future possibilities
for them
and for the children
from our community.
So thanks everyone and I'm
sure we'll continue our panel
of discussion now so.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Eldritch: I'm Eric
Eldritch I'm a program specialist
of the Office of Opportunity
of Inclusiveness and Compliance
and we were glad to be a
co-sponsor of the event today.
At this point, I would like to
ask our courtiers to come forward
and to give a quick overview of
the materials that they've brought
from the collections and then
this is also a good break,
if you are a library
employee and need to step out,
and then we will continue
the conversation.
So when Mike and others are
coming forward I'll let you know
that if you look in the back and you
get this and you get this book mark
with this book mark you get five
million pictures in your hands
and this is an amazing
trove comes from the prints
and photographs online catalog and
this material is readily available
to you 27/7 and we wanted
to let you know the prints
and photographs has materials
up there if American folkway
and geography and map if you would
come up and tell us a brief synopsis
of what's in your collection
and then we'll get back
to discussion with our panelist.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Judith Gray: Hello and greetings.
I'm Judith Gray from the
American Folk Life Center.
Our archive of folk culture holds
perhaps the largest collection
of one of a kind of field
recordings of tribal materials,
probably 2,000 hours representing
materials from 160-170 communities,
just within the U.S. and
some slightly boarding some
Canadian areas.
We also have recordings
from indigenous communities
in other parts of the world.
What I brought, however,
is not going to be much
of from this immediate area.
By the time the audio video
recording devices were around,
most of the acknowledges and
linguists were headed to parts
of the country where they
were larger concentrations
of people living in more traditional
ways perhaps at the time so most
of the recordings tend to be
plains, Southwest, California,
also quite a few New York Iroquoian
communities from the upper Midwest.
Yes, we have [inaudible]
from Minnesota, Wisconsin;
Menominee people and Iowa
people and such, but very,
very little from this
particular area.
So I can't provide you
with recordings like that.
I do have, however, for example,
the earliest of field recording
that we are aware of made 125
years ago, March 15th, 1890;
two Passamaquoddy men sang songs and
spoke narratives to a toy recordist,
so please stop and
I'll be glad to talk
with you further about
our resources.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Buscher: Good
Afternoon, I'm Mike Buscher.
I'm the head of Reference Services
with the Geography and Map Division.
We have the largest map
library in the world.
We have about 5.5 million maps.
Our collections related to Native
Americans are actually kind
of a hidden collection.
We've only cataloged less
than half of our collection,
so if you sit at home in
front of your computer looking
for historical maps we might have,
you're going to find a
very small percentage.
The way to actually get into this
collection is to make contact
with us or actually best
of all stop by for a visit.
But I would encourage you to take
a look at our website we have a lot
of our historical materials up,
at least some of our key items.
I brought the [inaudible] of the
1606 John Smith map if you want
to take a look at it, but the way to
really look into our collections is
to actually come visit
us and take a look.
There's a lot of great projects and
papers hidden in our collections.
Monday through Friday, 8:30
- 5, and you can connect
with us through our website.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Barbara Bair : Good afternoon.
I'm Barbra Bair.
I'm a historian in the Manuscript
Division here at the Library
of Congress and I've brought
a selection of items that are
from different parts of the
North America, from Canada
and the United States,
representative
of different tribal peoples.
In the manuscript division as a
whole, we have over 60 million items
in more than 11,000
collections and you can find many
of our materials online and also
in the virtual expedition sites
that are available through the
Library of Congress website.
Today after the discussion is
finished, you can come back
to see the materials that
I brought and they begin
with a Micmac Indian prayer book,
which is one of the earliest
known scripts of Native Americans,
and as Karenne pointed out,
all documents are subjective.
In other words, no
history its subjective.
They're created with an agenda,
created by certain authors
and with certain kinds of
collaborations, and everything
that we have is subject
is to interpretation
and re-interpretation over time.
The next item that I
brought was an illustration
from an 18th century ship captain's
diary of first nations people
in the [inaudible] sound off of
British Columbia, which is also one
of the earlier illustrations that
we have and I wanted to say that,
you know, one of the problems of
course with written sources is
that they are very new, they
are just tip of the iceberg
of actual history as has also been
pointed out by today's speakers,
that there's a very, very long
oral tradition that proceeds this.
The next item that I brought is
about the Red Stick Rebellion
and it's a list of names
Creek Indians who served
with the Tennessee Militia
under Andrew Jackson
and it makes the point that
it was a Creek civil war,
that there were native people's
on both sides, the Cherokee
and the Choctaw joined in
confederation with the lower Creeks
against the Red Sticks
who were very determined
to preserve traditional ways and
to work against the encouragement
of white culture and
of western expansion.
Related to that is a
letter that Principal Chief
of the Cherokee Nation, John Ross,
wrote to Andrew Jackson along
with other delegates from the
Cherokee nation protesting the
violence and the confiscation
of property in Georgia
and his long role in the 1830's and
reacting against Indian removal.
I've brought a few items from the
Henry Rowe Schoolcraft Collection
which is one of our
major collections
of Native American material
in the Manuscript Division.
Henry Rowe Schoolcraft, as you
may not know, was an Indian agent
in Michigan and became
superintendent of Indian Affairs
in the Detroit area once
Michigan became a state.
He married the Native American poet
who is now very famed and deservedly
so as the first Native
American poet who published
in the mainstream literary
tradition in the United States,
Jane Johnston Schoolcraft, and
I've brought a manuscript of one
of her poems and also an example
of one of the many Native American,
in this case Chippewa legends
and tales that were collected.
Henry Rowe Schoolcraft got credit
for the vocabularies and legends
that were collected, but Jane was
instrumental in all of that work,
and he could not have done
it without her family.
It was her family that provided the
contacts and introduced the people
that told the stories
that were transcribed
and we have several volumes of
those stories if you are interested
in the literary tradition
of the Chippewa.
I also brought a article
that Walt Whitman wrote.
He wrote it in the 1880's but it's
reminiscence of his time serving
as a civil servant at the Department
of the Interior where he worked
in the Department of Indian Affairs.
This was very briefly at the end
of the Civil War for a few months
and he wrote a very paternalistic
article about it later in life
and we do have the largest
collection of Walt Whitman papers
in the world here at the Library of
Congress and there are also drafts
in his collection of poems
that mention Native Americans
and he did prescribe to a very
romanticized vanishing race,
noble savage sort of vision
of Native American life
and the association with the
wilderness and I will just note,
because it came up
in the collection,
I mean in the earlier talks,
that we also have materials
on the beautiful city movement
because we have the
Fredrick Law Olmsted papers,
so there's a great deal
there about Native American
and other ethnic ideology and
symbolism that was replete
and that school of
architecture and landscape design.
The last items that I
brought are from are
from the C. Hart Merriam Collection.
C. Hart Merriam was an ethnologist,
archaeologist, zoologist,
and he did extensive work
in California and Nevada,
and I've brought one of his
hand colored and labeled map
that shows the linguist groups in
California and Nevada and also one
of his many field work vocabulary
forms, which in this case is
for the [inaudible]language.
One of the things that was
interesting about that is
that there is a category of names
for supernatural beings and one
of the things that he added in
by hand is the name for mermaid,
which was a reference to
tails of nymphs who lived
in the deep holes of
[inaudible] River.
So on that note, I'll pass it on.
[ Applause ]
>> So we do have a bit of time
to for some discussion but I want
to put this map up which is actually
in the Geography and
Maps Collection.
Gabby, this is the map that I
mentioned to you previously.
I meant to put this up before I
finished up, but this is a map
from late 19th century put
together by a symposium
of archeologists working
in the district.
It's a map of the District
of Columbia showing
"ancient village sights" and
you can see that triangles
and rectangles there indicating
sites within the district
that have been studied
at that point.
So I have two sets of questions
that I would like to offer
to our panelist and I would like
to invite any of you to come
up after I ask the first
set, and that is, you know,
we've got a number of
students in the room here.
Students of mine from George
Mason University came today
but were also being live cast
and a video of this panel will be
on the library's website so
potentially future students
who are interested in the
history of this region
and working with communities here.
All of you have devoted your lives
to this research, to this work,
to these communities, and so I'd
like to ask for those who would
like to do the same or would
be interested in the same,
what is some advice that
you would offer to them?
What are some things
that you would suggest?
What are some promises but also
what are some potential pitfalls.
What are things that researchers
wanting to work in this region
with communities here might want
to avoid, so I would like to open
up to whom whoever to
actually come up for this.
All together.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> We'll just make a little
panel here [laughing].
So pitfalls and opportunities.
Yeah so, I would have to say that
there are some really obvious issues
for research regarding people
across the board and in particular
in this region is that the material
is very early and the ability
to understand what the
Native point of view
on this is also, it's difficult.
So you have to go through many
different filters and sometimes go
to places that you wouldn't
think to go, so for example
so with Piscataway history,
we have the Jesuit relations,
we have the Maryland archives,
all of this being told
in English Colonial voice, sometimes
with reporting about how, you know,
basically supposed transcriptions
of what Native people had to say.
The way I started to
fill some of this in,
this is just a lifelong thing and
some of it is just pay attention
and start to have people who maybe
are doing other work pay attention
and sometime they'll start
to fill in the gaps so one
of the sources I did go
to, and it was really hard
to get my dissertation committee to
accept this all those years ago--
it took me a really long time
for them to finally get this--
was that I went to Haudenosaunee
to the Iroquois confederacy,
because some of our people had ended
up because of the pressures here,
they ended up in Pennsylvania coming
under Haudenosaunee Iroquois
jurisdiction and some
of our people got adopted into
the Cayuga Wolf Clan and ended
up in six nations, so this was
like, you're talking from about 1701
up through, it was
about the year 1987,
that I encountered Chief Jacob
Thomas Cayuga Wolf Clan chief
and I started to talk to him and I
said do you know anything, you know,
about us because they know us as
[inaudible] and he said, yeah I do,
and as a matter of fact I have
a binder here of written accord
of what happened in the Cayuga
language and it was like telling it
from the other side
of what had happened.
So there's fragments and weird
pieces and having to look around
and to do the unexpected
and to listen
to stories, hear people's names.
We have an oral account
about the Battle
of Fallen Timbers of
our people in 1794.
We have an oral account
of it that has to do
with that the people chose a
place that lightening hit trees
and that's why it's
called Fallen Timbers.
Fast forward a year to the 1990's
[inaudible] there's a guy whose
native name is Fallen Timbers.
I was like I need to talk to you and
so, you know, and so there's a lot,
it's just these little fragments
and pulling it together,
listening to what's involved in
terms of like other peoples' quoted
in songs, dances, oral account.
Sometimes hearing it when we're not
doing research but maybe we're all
at a protest together and we start
chatting, you know, or something.
So there's, yeah, there's
a lot there.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> So one pitfall I think I would
also add is, I would very, very,
very strongly encourage, I can't
stress enough, when you're looking
at these issues of indigenous
people, whatever it happens to be,
talk to indigenous people.
I've been involved in
too many situations
where the topic is something
involving Native Americans,
it's a very specific issue too
Native American communities,
and at the last second
a huge group of people,
I mean 20-30 people are trying
to put together an event,
maybe we should include a Native
American and they call you the day
of or something like
or the day before,
and you're like, and
yeah, you're one.
You know, you're like
one person, you know,
and there's this understanding,
yes, Native Americans are 2%
of the population, there's
not like a whole lot of us,
and you know the capacity is not
always there, but we are there.
And you will find someone that's
wiling to come and speak with you
about these things and you know
there's going to be someone
at that Nation or someone
that, you know, can connect you
to the right person to actually
get an indigenous perspective.
Only doing it straight from
research and, you know,
these often biased histories is not
the best way to go about things.
>> I guess one thing I would
like to add having been
on the Monacan Tribal
Council for about 12 years is
that that very often academics and
people who want to get PhD's come
to us with their projects and say,
can you help me, and they want us
to help them put this dissertation
together, and then they're going
to leave and we're never
going to see them again.
And our attitude over time has
become, we really don't have time
to help you in the sense that,
what are you going to do in return?
Are you going to build
a relationship with us
that will be mutually beneficial
or are we just helping you
get your PhD and that's it?
You know, and so often people
don't seem to understand
that there should be
an exchange, you know,
or some group of well-meaning
people in our neighborhood will come
and say, here's this project,
don't you think it's great,
we want you to approve of it.
And they didn't' ask us to be
involved in it the planning
of the project or consider
whether it would be useful to us
in terms of time as well.
So I think one of the things I
like to encourage people to do is,
before you begin a project, develop
a relationship that is respectful
and it might benefit both parties
so that there is an actual dialog
and that way everybody
feels included.
>> For me, thinking of what I do and
how to maybe encourage young people
out there may be watching this, that
maybe are interested in museums,
there's a lot of great programs
and I remember when I was a kid,
you know, I mean I didn't' think
I'd be working in a museum one day.
That thought never really entered
into my mind, but I ended up working
for a short time at our Pamunkey
Indian Museum and got interested
and got experience and
was able to come here,
but if you're very
interested, definitely look
at museum study programs, American
Indian study programs, yeah,
and learn how to fill out job
applications [inaudible] jobs.
That's really important.
>> So the other question that I
had and it's kind of more, I guess,
a little bit more pointed
maybe and that is when I think
about the history of Washington D.C.
and the history of the delegations
and diplomats coming into the
city over the past 200 plus years,
all of them are coming to negotiate
treaties with the federal government
but also making very
bold, very visible often,
statements about sovereignty.
When they do this, they're
not only making a statement
of about the sovereignty of their
own nations and at the capital
of the United States, but they're
also doing it on the homeland
of the Piscataway people
and within a broader region.
That makes Washington D.C.
a different kind of city
and when we think about the urban
indigenous history of Seattle
or Chicago or Detroit
or Minneapolis,
that's a different history than
Washington and I just wonder what,
and I think you all have different
perspectives to offer on this issue,
and I wonder what you
might think about that
or what you might say about that?
>> Okay [laughing].
Well, yeah, so here's to fast
forward a bit where, you know,
I was talking earlier about some of
this really deep ancestral history,
but given our location, that
has been absolutely integral,
part and parcel of what did
happen, what has happened next
and what continues to be
engaged with our community.
We have really been in many ways
hosting these delegations coming in,
the earliest ones that I
know my grandfather talked
about was relationships with people
coming into D.C. from the 1920's.
This is where he started doing,
sometimes recordings with people.
There was a few things that
actually there's cards for here,
but the sound recording was lost,
but that's where there's just
been this incredible energy back
and forth.
I think that's probably been
a very key factor to the way
that our community
really resuscitated,
was because of our location,
because of Native people coming in,
our folks encountering them,
having them come to stay with us.
I mean this was before people had
expense accounts and abilities
to host from the 1920's through the
1940's with the founding of the NCAI
through the 1950's and
particularly in the late 1960's,
a man maned Gene Shenandoah from
1970-71 came in as an advanced team
for the American Indian Movement,
ran into my uncle at a diner,
and they looked at each other
and they were like, hey.
And that meant that
our folks went whole
in on the American Indian Movement.
It meant that the couple
of people who hung
on to the culture suddenly got very
energized, started to interact.
They were at the [inaudible],
they were on the longest walk,
then they started going out West,
started going to Sundance's.
Our people started
intermarrying with people out West.
We were involved with the takeover
at Kinyonga up at Mohawk territory,
going with people to
lobby at congress
and then opening it
up hemispherically.
So we have a lot of contacts with
Amazonian, Central Americans.
We've married some of
those folks [laughing],
had kids with some of those people.
There's lot of like Turtle Island
Piscataways around and so I think,
yeah, that's been a huge factor back
and forth even though there's not
a lot of us, that it really started
to generate when we reincorporated
formally in 1974, we chose the date
of the Battle of Little
Big Horn to do it.
So, you know, yeah, it's been
a very active relationship.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> So I think her perspective
is probably one
of the more important ones,
since you are Piscataway.
It definitely is, you know, when
you come here it's often included
in any type of dialogue that
you have or at least, you know,
what I've seen of tribal leaders
talking to the federal government
to remind them that
we're on Indian lands.
That's always part
of the conversation,
is to remind them we're on
Indian lands because that kind
of really stands for a lot.
We're not here saying that, you
know, these old treaty rights
or whatever, which I would like to
add, the constitution [inaudible],
so I never understand that argument.
It's ridiculous.
But to remind them that, you know,
the reason that the United States is
here is because of the Indian people
that were and still are here.
So I do think, you know, it's
great when people come in from
out of town, and myself, I mean
the first thing you do is find
a community.
It's a little bit harder here.
I actually lived and worked
in Minneapolis for a long time
and that's where the American
Indian Movement was founded
and so we have a section and whole
area of town that's, you know,
you go there and you're
going to see lots of people
that you see all the time,
and you'll know exactly
that you're in your community.
It's a little bit different here.
It's not nearly as visible.
It's something where you
actually kind of have to have more
of a network of people to
figure out where you guys are.
It's a little bit harder,
and I think it kind of adds
to making it a little bit more
difficult, I guess, being out here
because where I'm from and where,
you know, a lot of us coming
from like, you know, the Southwest,
or you know, the Pacific Northwest
or the Midwest, we're used
to a really strong community
and here I think the community is
much, much smaller and, you know,
East Coast tribes are
a different situation.
You guys are in such a different
situation then we are but, you know,
creating those relationships
is incredibly important, so.
>> Well I would say that our
people have had a different history
and that we didn't come to
Washington to negotiate and that's
because the only treaty I'm
aware of that we were involved
with predates the establishment
of the United States.
And by the time other tribes
were coming negotiate,
our tribe was just hanging out in
the mountains trying to stay alive,
but it was very interesting to me
because when the National Museum
of the American Indian opened, so
many native people came to take part
in those events and our people were
among them, so they got to march
in the parade with all of
the other Indians nations
and to feel this incredible
validation and pride.
It's the only time I ever
felt really comfortable
in Washington D.C. because there
was so many Indian people around us.
So we have initiated more of a
dialog with other tribes and in
so doing also initiated dialogs
with political organizations
and have come here many,
many times on behalf
of our federal recognition bill
which is still in Congress.
>> It makes me think of, kind of
in a similar situation with Karenne
where we're not federally
recognized but still I do know
of some trips here to D.C. and
speeches that were given here
in D.C. and also a major
issue that we've had
in Virginia is the Racial
Integrity Act, you know,
it's a paper genocide where, you
know, we're not allowed to check
that box of being Native
American, and I know a lot
of Virginia native people
actually came here to D.C.
to get married just to be able to,
you know, check that box to say,
you know, on their
marriage certificate,
that they are Native Americans,
so that's definitely a big issue
that still is having impact
today for Virginia native people.
And also being here,
working here in D.C.,
it is always an interesting dynamic.
Being at the museum, there's a
lot of Native visitors we see
or even just somewhere around
in the city or suburb, you know,
a lot of times we might see
Native people and just kind
of like, hey where you from?
So, you know, and help people
sometimes feel more comfortable,
you know, people that are maybe
just coming here or just here
for a short business trip
and for whatever reason,
so it's always an interesting
dynamic as well, so.
>> Yeah, I just want
to follow up on that.
I mean that's, so this is a very,
I kind of mentioned it at the end
and you guys were talking about
this, very distinctive to this area
on the Atlantic seaboard,
Chesapeake in particular,
is the documentary Erasure of
Native People on the record,
so sometimes you'll see people
listed as Indians in the church
on church records or in other
kinds of ethnic graphical records
but on census, on being noted,
you know, free people of color,
sometimes from one
census to the next
or if a reservation was resolved,
once the reservations were
dissolved either legally
or generally illegally, you see the
change of designation from Indian
to free people of color,
free color, free negro.
And then, of course, like
you were saying in Virginia,
the category of Indian was outlawed,
it was prohibited until Loving
versus Virginia in 1967 with
the Racial Integrity Act.
It's astounding, so those
are the other things,
it's like you may be looking at
records that are Indian records,
but they don't appear that way
because you have to make a leap back
to an earlier document to
then trace it back forward,
so it's, you know, it's tricky.
>> We do have time for a
question or two from the audience
if anyone would like to ask
questions of our panelists.
>> Would you explain what you meant
by racial genocide, I
mean paper genocide?
>> So the question is, can
you explain by paper genocide?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Karenne Wood: We refer
to a specific instance
where a guy named Dr. Walter Plecker
and some of his colleagues managed
to lobby for the passage for
the Racial Integrity Act in 1924
which made it a felony for a
person of color to marry a person
that was considered white and
Plecker mounted a campaign
against Native people in particular,
correcting he thought
their birth certificate
so they did not say Indian and so
he changed their identification
racially to colored to
free issue or a number
of different terms had popularity
over the four decades he was
in power which effectively erased
the Native people of the region.
So when we say paper genocide
or documentary genocide,
he wiped out whole groups of
people in policy and on paper
where they continue to exist
but not with the identification
that they had for themselves.
>> Yeah, to me there is one
other piece of paper genocide
that is still very much an issue
today, which is [inaudible].
So when you meet a lot of people and
they ask, you know, what are you,
after I tell them I I'm a person,
I explain, yes, I'm Native American
and often people will
just say how much?
Which people don't understand,
that's incredibly offensive right.
I'm fully Native American, I'm 100
percent a citizen of my nation,
but that mentality comes from the
Policy of [inaudible] and so it has,
you know, there's a very, very set
idea to bleed Indians out, right.
That was kind of like the federal
government's intent was let's say
that you're not Indian
unless you're this much blood
because we're are going to decide
just randomly, you're 100 percent,
like so for instance my
own family, we have members
that are the same generation
but somehow they all have
different blood [inaudible]
because of how dark they were.
I mean, that is a really
common thing.
So it's those kind of politics,
once you're down to that, you know,
quarter or eighth or
whatever it happens to be,
then you're not Indian anymore.
And to me that's absolutely
paper genocide and it's something
that a lot of our nations
are struggling with.
My own, we don't have
blood [inaudible],
but we still have a little blood
[inaudible] on our cards still
to remind you that you're
only this much Indian.
And it's become a really
serious issue as far
as maintaining the memberships
that we have we have.
I mean many nations are very small
and if you can't marry outside your
own nation or you know if you have
to meet a certain amount of whatever
the federal government said all
those generations ago, it becomes a
real significant problem survival.
>> I see one more question
over here.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Yes, as I was mentioning earlier,
there is some work being done,
you know, just recently
with our Pamunkey language.
It's very similar to
Piscataway, and you could hear
when she was saying
some of the words,
you know, how similar they are.
So there is some work.
It's not, you know, fluently spoken
by anyone now, but, you know,
with this work there have been some
classes recently on the reservation
as well, so there's a little
work being done on that.
And also in my house with my wife.
My wife also is Pawnee, so
sometime she'll get out some things
and we'll start practicing
and teaching our son as well.
So yeah, it's going on.
>> I would encourage you to
download the Nichi app also.
That's [inaudible] of an
application to, you know,
have basically a pocket dictionary.
So language revitalization is very
serious, you know, across the board.
Every nation is fully aware of it.
There are a lot of congressional
members and currently we have,
you know, Senator Tester is
actually really supportive
of dedicating funding
to immerging schools,
to including Native
American curriculum,
you know, in public schools.
They are Native Americans going to
public schools, there's lots of us.
Most of us go to public schools.
I did. There's actually,
if you also want to look,
there's a [inaudible]
online dictionary.
The efforts to preserve the
languages are still here.
We are fortunate to have
lots of fluent speakers.
It's always so sad when
you hear about people
that don't have fluent
speakers left.
But language legalization is
absolutely happening and I think,
you know, Hawaii is a
really great example
of seeing incredible
success by, you know,
accommodation of immerging schools
and developing these
modern applications
to children speaking
the language again
and get their parents speaking
the language with them, so.
>> Thank you for that question.
I think saving our languages
is so important because the way
that we think is embodied in
the way that we talk, you know,
and how we translate the world
through the words that we use,
so it's really essential
that we retain our languages
if we still have them or try
to bring them back if we don't.
In the face of my people, the
Monacan people, our language,
the closest related language,
which is called [inaudible]
and it was actually
documented in Canada after some
of our people went there
and affiliated themselves
with the Haudenosaunee Iroquois
people and it was documented there,
so my PhD is actually in linguistic
anthropology and that's the language
that I'm working with, trying to
ascertain what is most important
to my people about
brining that language back
so that once we began a
language revitalization program,
we'll be able to target
the areas they most want
to learn about effectively.
And what we've learned is that
they really want to be able to pray
because they feel like that is their
natural language that corresponds
to our homeland geography and to
the ancestors that have died there.
And we do our reburial ceremonies
which we've done 4 of them,
they want to be able to talk
to the ancestors in the words
that they would recognize.
>> In a moment, I'm going to ask
John to come up and say a few words,
but I'd like you to join me in
thanking these amazing panelists.
I'm so astounded by these folks.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And then we'll go ahead and step
down off the podium and ask John
to come up and say a few
words before we break.
Thank you.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> John Van Oudenaren: I'm John Van
Oudenaren, the Director of Scholarly
and Educational Programs
at the Library of Congress,
and I'm here to represent
the Kluge Center.
The mission of the Kluge Center, in
case somebody didn't say it before,
is to bring together scholars and
researchers from around the world
to stimulate and energize
one another, to steal wisdom
from the library's rich
resources, and to interact
with policymakers of the public.
And I think what we've seen here
today is just a great example
of that actually happening
with a researcher
and people coming in from outside.
Erica asked me to make an
announcement about the program.
At 2 o'clock, we continue with
a program sponsored or run
by the Law Library on the
Indigenous Tribal Law Portal.
I know they've put a
lot of work into this,
so you'll want to see this.
And then at 3 o'clock, there's
a tour of the great hall
and then you go up to the
rare books reading room
where I'm sure they'll have some
interesting things to see related
to the top, so thank you very
much and thanks for [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Carrie Lyons: Good afternoon and
welcome to the Library of Congress
as we celebrate Native
American Heritage Month
and thank you all for coming.
My name is Carrie Newton Lyons.
I am a research manager
and legislative attorney
in the administrative law section
of the American law division
of congressional research
service here at the library.
I'm also a citizen of the Cherokee
nation of Oklahoma and a member
of the library's group of Native
American Employees and Colleague.
And I would like to first send a
thanks to those folks who have,
from the group today, for
shepherding the program
and the events and making them
happen, so thank you and thank you.
As you know, this program will
be highlighting the library's
indigenous tribal law portal, but
before the demonstration begins,
I want to take a few moments
to make some brief comments
about the importance of the
project, especially in light
of Native American Heritage month.
It's probably obvious that the
indigenous law portal will provide a
valuable resource and tool
for analysts and academics,
practitioners and students
of both federal Indian law
and federal Indian policy as
well as tribal law and policy.
Well, and as an attorney
who has worked in the field
of federal Indian law for quite
some time, I can speak directly
to the value of the portal as a
resource that will provide access
to an array of tribal
laws and documents
that are necessary for that work.
But, I also want to highlight
and speak more about the value
of the portal outside of the
practice of law and outside
of scholarship on tribal
law and policy.
Since the portal will
provide an outstanding vehicle
for generally educating people about
Indian tribes and Native Americans.
As many of you many
know, Native Americans
and Indian tribes are often
viewed as historical entities.
Part of American history that
is taught in schools as relics
of the past such as sharing food
with the Pilgrims at Thanksgiving,
but people are not often taught
that Indian tribes continue to exist
as sovereign nations with
governments and judicial systems
that create, enforce, and adjudicate
their laws within the nations.
This portal, however, will
provide a tool for educating people
about Indian tribes as
they currently exist
and as they currently operate.
This portal will show that tribes
have constitutions and laws
that are created and amended as
the tribes continue to develop
and deal with modern day issues.
This portal will also show that
tribes have legislative branches
that inact ordinances, regulations,
and laws and executive branches
that enforce the laws, and judicial
branches that interpret the laws
and make decisions that set
precedence for the tribes.
This portal will allow people to
access not only documents relating
to Indian land sessions in
the 1700s and 1800s but also
to the 2013 amended constitution
of the Seminole Nation
of Oklahoma demonstrating
that Indian tribes are not
historical entities locked
in the past but vibrant and
current, self-governing nations
that importantly contribute
to American society.
So again, thank you on behalf of the
library's Native American Employees
and Colleagues, and I hope that
you enjoy the program today.
[ Applause ]
>> Roberta Shaffer: Let me add
my welcome to Carrie's welcome.
My name is Roberta Shaffer,
and I have the pleasure
of serving currently as
the acting Law Librarian.
We didn't confer on our
notes, but we should have
because basically my prepared
remarks track Carrie's almost
to a t. And therefore,
it shows, well,
I'm going to say not
so much great minds.
This is so obvious and so
important that you don't have
to have a great mind to see
that this project is truly
breaking new ground for the Library
of Congress and serves
so many purposes,
not the least of which
is the proof of concept
that Native American
tribes are alive and well
in organic legal systems just
like any other legal
jurisdiction in the world today.
But the beauty of the portal
is really multifaceted.
First and foremost, I want
to say that for the Library
of the Congress, it represents
a change in the way that we look
at the entire classification
concept, and so for that alone,
I applaud the woman who has really
born all of the bricks and mortar
for that, and that is
Dr. Yolanda Goldberg,
who is sitting in the audience.
I don't know if you can pan her,
but let us all just flatter
her with some applause.
[ Applause ]
She, with the permission of
Beacher Wiggins, the head of one
of the major sections
of library services,
conceived of this ideology,
this concept of moving
from a historical approach
to a geopolitical approach
to organizing the information and
then going that next step of linking
to external websites and sources
so that a person can really almost
do a one-stop shop by, believe it
or not, using a classification
system.
And so today we are really
marking a moment in which the idea
of the word classification system to
describe accessed information goes
out the window and we
now finally can say
that classification is
a roadmap, is a guide,
is a handbook for knowledge.
So I applaud Yolanda and Tina Gein
[phonetic] who worked with her
from the law library
originally, and now the 2 people
who will be actually
demonstrating the portal for you
from the library staff, and that
is Robert Brammer-I'm just looking
down at my paper because I don't
want to get his title wrong-and
so he is Senior Legal Reference
Specialist, and Jennifer Gonzalez
who is an information
analyst in the library.
The final thing that I do want
to say also about the value
of this port is, that it enables
one of the greatest assets
of the Library of Congress as
a clearinghouse of knowledge,
and that is that not only
does one now have access
to the Seminole 2013
Constitutional Amendments,
but there's an opportunity
to now compare among
and between the documents
of indigenous peoples
and other sovereign
nations all over the world.
And this is as truly important
thing in today's times
where no legal system exists as
an island an all legal systems
and all peoples of the world want to
compare and contrast their cultures,
their commercial way of
life, their community habits,
their civilizations to those
of the past, of the present,
and by way of these
portals to the future.
So thank you for stepping
into the future with us,
Dr. Yolanda Goldberg, and the rest
of you who are here this afternoon.
And without further ado,
Robert and Jennifer.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Robert Brammer: Okay,
I'll bring up the site.
Okay, let me start by saying,
researching indigenous
law can be very difficult.
Often, the only source of the
materials, current materials,
is the tribes themselves.
And if you're looking for historical
materials, they're often spread
around many different sites.
So to approach this challenge, the
indigenous law portal is organized
around Dr. Goldberg's K
classification system.
Providing a portal that
combines the Library
of Congress's vast
historical resources
with particularly historic
constitutions, charters,
and codes with links to
current sources of law
from the tribes themselves.
That said, I want to mention what
the portal is not do is identify
every single law that's
applicable to a given tribe.
That's beyond the scope
of the project.
The indigenous law portal
is integrated into law.gov,
the Law Library of Congress site,
and it initially focused
on the United States.
We've branched out
to Canada and Mexico
and in the future it
will incorporate laws
and regulations effecting Native
Americans, particularly treaties
and acts from the U.S.
statues at large.
The metadata provided in
the portal is very detailed,
built around Dr. Goldberg's
classification schedule.
And I want to go ahead and
illustrate that by clicking
on Canada and going to Ontario
and now I'm going to bring
up the source of the page.
[ Background Sounds ]
So I'm scrolling down
to illustrate this.
So here you have the name of a
tribe and then you have the div ID
which provides the
classification for the tribe source
from Dr. Golderberg's work.
So that's how imbedded the metadata
is, the classification schedule,
and the metadata of the site.
[ Background Sounds ]
Sorry. Just going back here.
Okay, so let's talk about
how you use the portal.
First you choose a country.
I'm not sure why I'm not
getting a map loading here.
I apologize for that.
We've got this great clickable maps
that were provided by [inaudible]
that allow you to just click
on a state and go directly
to that state's materials
and the tribes represented
within the boundaries of that state.
So at the top, we've
got general resources
for indigenous legal materials.
And if you scroll down, those
resources include gateways,
directories, research guides,
topic-specific resources
such as here you see
like economic law.
You've also got links to NGOs,
IGOs, and indigenous organizations.
Below that, you've got a link to Dr.
Goldberg's classification schedule
and the table of contents for
this is actually clickable.
So you can choose the location
that you're interested in
and then see the classifications
associated with that location.
Below that, you have a link to the
digitized historical constitutions
as a separate collection.
These are also represented
throughout the site
with the tribe they're
associated with.
And then below that, you
have links to tribes.
You can browse tribes
by region, state,
and also an alphabetical listing.
So I'm going to go ahead and
go to state and choose Oklahoma
to illustrate some of the
resources that we have on the site.
I'm going to choose the
Cherokee Nation and I'm going
to choose the constitution and laws
of the Cherokee Nation from 1875.
So this is an example of one
of the historical resources
from the Library of Congress
that has been digitized.
I find this one particularly
interesting
because it's actually
written in Cherokee.
Here we go.
I want to mention that not
everything on the site is written
in the, you know, the
tribe's language.
So there's a lot of resources that
even if you can't read the language
that you can certainly make use of,
but I just found this particular
interesting as an example of one
of the historical resources
on the site.
Okay, next I'm going to go
to Washington and I'm going
to choose the [inaudible] Tribe.
And this is just an example of
how we link to current sources
of a tribe's law by linking directly
to their website and also below
that you see the [inaudible]
order code.
This is actually hosted by one
of the partners that we link
to to flush out the site, the
National Indian Law Library.
[ Background Sounds ]
Okay. Now, I'm going to Alaska and
specifically the Twin Hills Village.
And this is just another
example of how we're looking
for current sources of law we link
directly to the tribes themselves,
making the sites easy to find
by organizing in the portal.
So I want to mention that this
product is a collaboration both
within and outside of the wall
of the Library of Congress.
Of course, Dr. Goldberg's great work
on the K classification schedule,
the Law Library, our
fantastic interns,
[inaudible] great clickable maps,
the Geography and Maps Division,
and partners outside of the library,
the National Indian Law Library,
the Law Library of Microform
Consortium all were essential
to the success of this project.
We encourage feedback from
all of our stakeholders
and we've already incorporated
feedback
that we've received into the site.
Hawaii, Central and South
America are our next projects
for inclusion into the portal.
And with that, I'm going to turn it
over to Jennifer who's going to talk
about law.gov's resources for
American Indian legal materials.
Law.gov is the Law
Library of Congress site.
[ Background Sounds ]
> Jennifer Gonzalez: Hello.
Out front, if you have not
received it, we have little handout
that has all of the URL's that
we've been talking about today,
including the indigenous law portal
URL which happens to be quite long,
because we want, we have to fit
into the website, so what I wanted
to do is to start off by
showing you an easy way to get
to the indigenous law portal.
The easiest way is to type in
law.gov and that will bring you
to the Law Library's home page.
Scrolling down slightly you'll
see this guide to law online
with the law square, indigenous
right here is in purple.
That'll bring you directly
to the indigenous law guide.
This is the easiest way to get there
instead of typing in that long,
this long URL that you see up here.
The law library's website also
has several other resources,
some of these resources we
are trying to include and some
of them are proving a little
difficult so we're working on them
but we want to be able to
show you all the resources
that the Law Library of Congress and
Library of Congress has available
for indigenous legal materials.
[ Background Sounds ]
So headed back to the homepage, we
have law.gov, and scrolling down,
I said that under this
guide to online is
where the indigenous
law portal is housed.
The guide to online also
has many other materials
that could be helpful.
If you click on nations,
you'll see that every nation
in the world is represented in here.
This is a great place
to start for any sort
of research on any other nation.
And U.S. Federal is specifically
where we have other
American Indian material
that has not been incorporated.
If I scroll down, you'll
see that we have an Indians
of North America guide and this
is for U.S. Federal law that has,
the indigenous law guide is
for indigenous legal materials.
Legal material that are Native
to those indigenous nations,
but the U.S. has also created
lots of legal material in regards
to the Native Americans
population that live
within the geographical borders.
And so this is what this
material here is for.
We have text, commentary, different
links to different agencies
and again another guide to
the indigenous law portal.
[ Background Sounds ]
We are hoping to include many of
this material into the portal soon,
but for now this is where it's
housed in sort of the same area.
Headed back to law.gov, again to
the homepage and scrolling down,
below the guide to online is
our section of legal reports.
The Law Library writes reports
primarily for congress and if I go
to the comprehensive
index we can see some
of this report is written
actually on indigenous material.
These are the four reports so
far that we have on our website
about indigenous material.
This one in particular
is quite interesting.
It's the preservation
of historical cemeteries
and it includes some
information on the United States.
So clicking on the name of
the report brought us here
to the report page and then
in this table of contents box,
clicking on the United States brings
up some of the United States portion
of the report that was written
discussing of the preservation
of the historical cemeteries in the
U.S. Okay, scrolling back to the top
and headed back to law.gov.
Also from our homepage, if we
click on research and reports,
I'm going to head a little bit
farther deeper into the website
so that you can see more
of our materials that might
or maybe hidden in there.
The first one here, again we
clicked on research and reports
of commemorative observances.
This is a collection of
materials that is all
about just different commemorative
observances that we have
in the U.S., one of them being the
American Indian Heritage month.
We have an overview of the
month, legislative branch,
executive branch documents, and web
resources specifically on, again,
the Native American heritage month
again these proclamations will bring
you to a pdf.
[ Background Sounds ]
Excuse me [laughing].
Okay, our pdf that is the
proclamation from the president
about the National American Indian
Heritage Month in the year 2007.
So while the portal is a
one stop shop, excuse me.
Well the portal is a one stop shop
for all the indigenous
legal materials,
again this is another place
where we have materials
that don't exactly
fit into the confines
of the portal that
we wanted to show.
Okay, law.gov again,
research and reports,
and then here we have
some digitized material.
This first link, American Indian
Constitutions and Legal Materials is
where all of those links that
Robert was showing you before
from the portal, where they live.
Again we have a clickable
map for different regions.
And this is the South.
This is our earliest
material and it starts
with 1810 in the Cherokee Nation.
This is also the place where you
can find the material [inaudible]
of language of the tribe or
the [inaudible] of the tribe.
And we have it noted here
by saying, in Cherokee
or we several different
ones, there's one in Choctaw,
and so you can download
this pdf and quickly view.
There you go.
And quickly view the document.
[ Silence ]
Okay, I'll go back to the South
and scroll down to where we were.
Our historical materials continue
on through the 1950's-1960's
with these constitutions
and corporate charters.
These two materials happen to
be in several different places
on the internet, but these
are pdfs that we've digitized
from the Library of
Congress's collection.
There are also some gems in
here for these older materials.
[inaudible] I'm going
to search for this one.
We have some ordinances that I
have found extremely interesting
and continue to find interesting
as I keep going through.
This is ordinances of this town.
We can just look at some of
the different titles here.
You have an ordinance
about dead animals.
Yep [laughing].
Many different ones, in regard to
dogs, taxes, oh, I haven't found--
my favorite one is up here.
Where is it?
Oh no. There we go, this
is one of my favorite ones.
Bean shooting [inaudible]
for boys only.
They were not concerned
about girls, it seems.
And no destroying of
bird nests [laughing].
So this is one of my favorite
documents that we have.
I wanted to make sure I showed you.
Okay, now back to research and
reports and digitized material.
I'm going to continue going through.
We have some collections from
the Law Library of Congress here,
but we also have Statues at
Large and United States Treaties.
These are two collections
that we are working
on increasing what we have available
currently, but here at the Statues
at Large you are able to access
all of the historical statues
at large from 1776 through 1950.
Some of them are available
by chapter which means
that you'll be able to look at
each of the individual titles
and control F to find
those titles a lot quicker.
I'm going to go to Congress
21 and you can see that each
of these titles here
with an individual pdf.
So up here at the top you can
download the full congress
or you can download
the small pdf's here
that would just get you
the chapter or the law
that you are really looking for.
I'm going to scroll down to chapter
148 to give an example of one
of the Indian Laws that we have.
This is an act to provide
of an exchange of lands
with the Indians residing of
any of the states or territories
and for the removal
west of the Mississippi.
This is the Indian Removal Act that,
they didn't call it that back then,
but this is was the actual title
for that, and so by clicking
on this pdf, you will be able
to open up and directly read
that statue starting here.
[ Background Sounds ]
Sorry, I'm going back to the
Statue, I forgot to show that each
of these statues, the advantage of
breaking up each of these statues
by title means that we are able to
individually put metadata into each
of these statues so that they are
available to be searched exactly.
So for instance, this statue about
the Indians Removal Act had all
of these terms here applied to it,
so the search on the libraries
main page putting in any
of these terms will get
you straight to this act.
Okay and I also mentioned treaties.
These are the treaties that
the United States assigned
with other nations.
This treaties series so far does
not include any of the treaties
that the United States has signed
with American Indian Nations.
Those were in a separate
volume of Statues at Large
that we are currently
working on very hard to get
up as quickly as possible.
But we have these treaties
currently,
which will show some international
treaties that have happened
that have to do with
American Indians
or Native peoples of anywhere.
So typing in Indian brings
us a search to this Inter-
American Indian Institute and
clicking on this pdf will show
that this is something that has been
signed in 1940 and it was trying
to create an Inter-American
Indian Institute.
Okay, there's one more historical
source that I wanted to mention.
Let's close out some of these tabs,
And I'm going to go back to law.gov
and click on find legal resources.
Legislative resources.
Again this link is quite long,
but the URL is in your handout
and century of law making is here.
This is still the Library
of Congress website
and it has the first hundred
years of legal documents here.
So many different things, bills,
statues at large, journals.
I'm going to click here
to the Annals of Congress.
This is what is the current
congressional record or precursor
to the current congressional record,
which means all of the things
that congress has said
or went on in that day.
If I browse the page headings and
go to I and scroll down a little,
we have, these are all
of the different topics
of what congress spoke about in
regards to Indians during this time.
So for example I will click on
Indian fur trade in the Senate.
They've spoken about this 5
times and so clicking on one
of these will bring you directly
to the page that they talked
about the Indian fur trade.
So that's it for historical
documents that we have
from the Library of Congress and
now we have some current documents.
And I have that, that we are
going to go to congress.gov.
This is available in multiple
places in our website but typing
in congress.gov works just as well
and brings you here
to this main page.
The easiest way to get to
the indigenous materials
that we have here is
to click on browse.
And scroll to this
where it says bills
to subject policy area
and policy areas.
Each of the bills that congress puts
out that has one policy
area that is attached to it.
And here we have Native
Americans which is one of,
they only have a few
subjects here to choose from
but Native Americans have 97 bills
so far with this current congress.
Clicking on Native American
gets you those 97 bills.
As you can see several
have not gotten
to far they are just now
introduced here, using these facets
on the left hand side
you are able to navigate
and see exactly what it
is you are looking for.
So you have bills and resolutions,
let's say I only want bills,
it will redo the search and
only give me those 93 bills
and take out the resolutions.
I can narrow this down and can
only look at the 3 that became law
and we have other facets here that
you can narrow down with the bills
down by sponsors, committee,
chamber or party.
So I have the 3 bills that have
passed, but if you wanted to look
at an expand the search you
can come here to the congress
and currently we have
the 114 congress checked
which is our current congress,
but by showing more you can look
at all the bills, or in this case
the laws since they've passed
and become law, that were
passed by congress in each
of the different congressional
years.
[ Background Sounds ]
So again, law.gov will get
you here to this portal.
That's the quickest link.
Let's see if that map is working.
Nope. Not yet.
But the Canada one is,
so you can see there.
We have each of the regions
here in a certain color and each
of the different territories
or provinces are highlighted
there so you can go through.
So we welcome any questions that
you have, any questions today
that you have, or if you have
any help that you could give us
on the portal any suggestions
that you have,
we would absolutely welcome it.
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
Any questions?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
>> Jennifer Gonzalez: Right, we are
doing as much outreach as we can
to try to speak with the tribes,
to let them know about the portal
and all of the availability
that we have.
I think the first step is really
making sure that people know
about the portal and know that it's
out there and once people start
to recognize that its out there
and then hopefully those
relationships will really start
to be developed.
[ Background Sounds ]
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
I think I will open that up
to anyone else [laughing].
No, that's quite alright.
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
>> Jennifer Gonzalez : Fantastic.
Anymore questions?
Great. Thank you.
Well, make sure that you get
a handout when you leave,
so that you have all those URL's
or now you know how to find them.
Thank you.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Right.
>>Robert Brammer : Typically, we
use USA.gov as a link shortener.
I think that's usually the
standard process [inaudible].
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Robert Brammer: Thank you.
>> Jennier Gonzalez: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay, thank you very much.
Thanks Robert and Jennifer
for an outstanding program.
That was really, really good.
Before everyone departs, I
just want to hand out a couple
of other thank yous as well.
First I want to thank Eric
Eldritch here [applause].
Yes. Eric was instrumental
in putting this full
day seminar together,
getting the panels together,
getting the programs together,
getting the displays that were out
here earlier today together as well.
Did a fantastic job and thank you
so much for putting this together
for us today, this morning and
this afternoon, so thanks, Eric.
>> Eric Eldrich : It
was a team effort.
>> And, of course, I want
to thank everyone here
who attended today's seminar.
We really appreciate your support
of American Indian Libraries
and connecting them to federal
libraries, connecting them
with the federal government in
general, and getting the word
out there that American Indian
Libraries and American Indians,
in general, are important parts
of American cultural history,
American history in general, and
we need to continue to support them
and work with them to get
the resources and services
that they deserve to have.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov